[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Sunday Sunday
what's going on around we back we back
2023 how my levels is going what are we
doing around what's going on start doing
right quick we'll see the clown what's
up kick in the door wave in the 4-4 2023
we just got games though got wig we
ain't got no games okay okay I see what
you're doing
Lydia Master what's going on
[Music]
but something's wrong with me you're
ridiculous attic I can keep doing things
no I really haven't done nothing uh
anyway no you sound fine no we haven't
it's something wrong you're ridiculous I
would talk to the people moving on
Yo Lord Ray what's up what's going on he
said I got the chosen okay Sith Lord
what's up
Man Without Fear you know what I'm
saying pikon pecan you don't always put
your name what's up oh wait heck what's
going on
in the building salute salute salute
crunchy what's going on okay it's not in
the building this is the day no doubt oh
I got some new names in here oh Anthony
boy this back hold on okay
c-u-n-y stand up good to see you back
brother no doubt Contee what's up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he said I know the design topic flaw is
King
I wonder whose topic chose was that but
anyway I didn't talk to the people
he up to something y'all watch him
anyway King Solomon was going on
nice little respite but uh we gotta talk
to the people we gotta catch up with
y'all there's a lot of things
we need to see what's up we got the
birthday boy we'll be pulling up Lord
saw his birthday week you know what I'm
saying we got Attic in the building of
course
you know what I mean so uh live
Supremacy what's going on so it's a
shout out you already know
have a good time yeah it's good to be
back it's good to be back the rest was
needed but um
Big Year a lot of plans and um I can't
wait to get to y'all man on these Topics
in the Realms good to see y'all up here
early in the congregation
[Music]
yes please hit the like button please
when you come in and I'm saying make
sure you don't take the shoes off you
know what I'm saying at the door keep
the rug clean you know what I'm saying
make sure you salute everybody cause the
realm is back don't take your shoes off
from my place
[Music]
we'll be back we're gonna give you some
Dallas bars and I'll see you in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want a compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when he was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain uses a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest to
start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got that's
[Music]
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
a problem
[Music]
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies you still
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this and you're cubicle on the Lord's
day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord radio
[Music]
hot mics and all that oh let's do some
mic checks right quick in the new year
right quick
he's some levels can I see some levels
people the most beautiful thing in this
world
right now
all right we had gotta finishes
[Music]
can you hear you it was great and we are
live happy New Year and welcome to 2023
and welcome back to the iron Lords
podcast LLC and the Lords of gaming.net
we are back what's going on people
episode number 286 26 year old getting
close to some I know some Milestones I
like 286 man it gets close to 300 maybe
300 something happens take that take
that take that take that anyway another
Glory Sunday we're back at the round
table and the Lord
today we've got thoughts on a potential
Xbox game showcase PS5 tops 30 million
and Sony CES presents crazy yeah new
redfall details and a PS5 design flaw to
discuss yeah
we will let you guess whose topic that
is
so we gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original gaming Knights here at
the realm of the Round Table my co-host
with Nicole Mouse my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf Lord addict of the
attic show happy New Year brother how
you doing doing pretty good I think
we're a little bit past uh New Year but
uh I mean
the first show it again and then you
know we're still within range
so I don't know what y'all talking about
I was around
[Laughter]
first of all I want to say that people
in the chat man you guys got to watch r
r with the Lords of being King uh you
know King is working his way up the
attack on Titan wall but maybe Giants
wow
no genitalia wow
he has went from hating the show to
mildly liking it okay
shout out to attic Hayden bakkie what's
up what's up with that Bucky he's hot
garbage
you know put the bushes in the chat if
addict need to get in that
okay again I want to hear this somebody
hit why
okay you can hear why on uh
tell me you didn't watch it or no
yeah so um it's all there right there
slow mo we agree on something oh wow
slow mo you my fortnite partner do not
let me get you kicked out
dip down Animes in the building he signs
off one large oh come on bro
and what's funny is she is on the lights
on Attack on Titan he hasn't even seen
the Milestone the stuff that the reason
people love that anime like he gonna
flip out when he sees Levi
I saw Levi already Levi's Levi is purely
the the most beastiest he's the most
arrogant what happened
like Levi walked through the room yo how
the dude gonna die and he said Levi just
tell me you're gonna avenge me it didn't
tell me my life meant something
he grabbed this dude hand I thought
Levi's gonna say something disrespectful
he grabbed a dude handset yes I'm going
to take your courage with me
I will go out there and I will handle it
what episode are you on I'm on episode
get busy
I'm talking to you Tuesday about that
that's some R&R flavor yeah so uh been
playing a lot of fortnite you know
they're bringing Pokemon to fortnite
really easy yeah I saw a trailer
yeah I sent an addict some of the new
promo stuff you know you know what it is
you know what it is so I can let that
release they've seen that opening
engagement for that Mario thing I have a
feeling once that Mario thing Tech goes
off like Nintendo gonna open the floor
because I I don't think a lot of those
people realize how much money they can
make off putting their their skins on uh
on fortnite I just want to watch you
songs once Mario pops up on there like
bearing to you you're sucking six horses
you'll see Zelda you'll see all types of
stuff yeah
do whatever he wants but you know the
poor dude that's making a his own little
game on the side he got to go to jail he
got to go to jail
that's been it addict besides your
enemies and games what games we play Man
uh playing to fortnite I've been playing
Echo chained uh but if that game is
seems to be a lot longer than I
originally anticipated
I finally finished tactics uh oh girl
Tactics Ogre I had like eight days in
that game oh damn no damn yeah yeah
that's a long game and I was climbing
this thing called um
the house of the dead or something like
that Palace of the dead and there's like
100 Floors
and originally I was like I'm just gonna
let the AI I'm not doing 100 Floors the
AI is going to play 100. and I got to
like floor 65 70 I'm like oh the a I
can't beat these people now like they
they destroying them and I'm like well
I'm not playing uh 15 floors I'm not
playing 25 floors out 35 floors I play
one more floor so then I just shut that
that thing down I was like it's not
happening that's what I'm doing at the
AI could do that I kind of like that
concept but you can have it yeah that's
what I did I wish more stuff is it sad
that I got something like the AI but I'm
like why couldn't you just simulate the
whole battle
like I actually thought that way about
XCOM like after you consistently keep
doing them over and over again it's just
like just let me send me like the battle
if I lose I lose it like like it should
come up it's like simulate the battle
the percentage of losing everyone and
because I'll be op and they'll make me
play the same battle I just play ten
minutes ago just let me simulate it I
guess you know devil could be like you
gotta want you to play the game hey
everybody but anyway but now I hear you
going but that's what it is Sir
yeah that's pretty much it you know uh I
had a pretty good uh break you know it
didn't really break because you came
back I was like oh we live once I was
like we back
a little bit of a break a little bit
that show was probably one of your best
shows I had people in my DM hit me up
you know like your attic show was crazy
yeah yeah yo it made me go watch your
show when it's entity I was like what
the hell people was like yeah people ask
me they're like where you at I'm like
where we at yeah
[Laughter]
well originally I was going to do it the
day before but then I was like you know
what let me do it during iops time slot
so at least there would be some content
for that you just wanted to post uh uh
uh potential uh people
I prefer
I prefer the time slots that we actually
do shows to have something playing and
if we can't then I will easily rotate a
show if there's no show going on he
learned that from Comcast
so what what is this in my normal time
slide what
I like this show shout out to the room
AC addict held it down no doubt yeah
about my shirt it's a Kakashi shirt from
Naruto he hate Kakashi Takashi it's a
Takashi shirts
no it just says snitching like nothing
they show him in the booth
all right the new Takashi joint oh they
got ninjas I like it this this is like
Naruto yeah yeah that's the one that we
wanted you to watch
this is my favorite character oh that
one right there what's up butt naked
Giants ain't for you you know what's for
you though the one that he don't like
because it's about fighting okay okay
for us for the streets wow
selfish experience and also the softer
Thomas the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank in recent
birthday party Lord Sovereign
[Laughter]
what happened was I I left it to Twitter
right and Twitter always comes up for me
right so it was like it was midnight and
my wife gave my presents let's get my
presents right everybody nice and
whatever whatever and then I go to
Twitter I'm like where's my balloons
so I'm like I know I didn't change my
settings
you turn that off just so he could
specifically roast us for this yeah it's
a light roasting a light roasting you
know but uh yeah so no balloons that
whole day I was like what's going on
this is what happened when you game in
the vacuum yeah it's just that Circle
play itself I was not worthy of the
balloons because my lack of posting yeah
you gotta hit a quota of a bedtime
rules now man it's not about me
it says when you join oh now oh oh it
got your hoes joint out now he's lost I
don't know if you've checked your
account sir but uh if you look at it
right now
I don't know if you want that out but oh
really oh yeah I'm looking at it's right
now it's all outside you're outside with
the information on Twitter
I was like where's my balloon balloons
but you know what's funny
you may not have had that visible
because I've never seen that on your
profile before yeah
it's come up it's come up before in past
years yeah past years has been fine so I
was like I know I didn't touch the
profile okay so I don't know something
on the back end change but that's fine I
love y'all anyway
47 in the the road to 50 continue
but it was a it was a good holiday man I
didn't do a lot of gaming but I did a
lot of sleeping good though
I mean really I was on some real noonish
1pm type stuff yeah for the most part it
was a couple of days I had to get up
early but a lot of resting what I did
game I did uh on the steam deck I was
playing uh Resident Evil 4 because I'm
just excited for the Remake and I know
it's going to be kind of different so I
wanna I just want to see Resident Evil 4
again because I haven't played it since
the GameCube like I haven't touched it I
think I've beat that game at least once
again yeah that was one of the most
racist residents
it was straight up right here
they were in space
I know they were speaking Spanish
now but they were they were Spanish it
was Spanish with
me and John we used to like be in
parties and we just started what are you
buying what are your salad
yo that was the first time they
introduced the dude
evil
knobs
just be Ryan would just be like playing
like fortnite you know or something and
I just hear him say thank you you just
do the random yeah
I'm trying to remember no it was just
the the what's your book called it the
whatever they call the salesman yeah
something like that you know what's
funny you could kill him and he'll never
show back up the rest of the game oh you
should play without a store yeah oh
that's crazy yeah
[Music]
that's hard mode that's how you don't
like hard mode
I mean and some more um not a war yeah
and but Tana came as a long-ass game uh
so I got a little more story no I did it
I can't I can't even I can't even front
like the further I get into that game
what really jumps out at me is no the
the the the acting the relationships is
is always what draws me into the games
right the relationship with cradles and
his son the uh uh other relationships
that come up that uh fractured you know
kind of things like we talk about old
games
relevant for me for like another six
months because that's how long it's
gonna take me to beat it but
um check out my review on the island
floors yes
for like three days four days
um but again I was talking to King about
this over the over the break and I was
just like
it is like you know what it is they give
you a lot more in terms of the combat
the options the skill trees and stuff
but what happens is like in any game
like this you start to just gravitate to
what you like right and then you don't
really start using all that other stuff
so right I find myself gravitating to
the same sort of skill set that I had in
the first God of War game so I'm playing
because that's just the way I like to
play it might be a couple little things
that deviate a little bit but for the
most part I feel like I'm playing the
same way they give you extra stuff you
do have like uh like more ambulance and
stuff that give you sort of power ups
and Buffs but beyond that I'm still kind
of playing it the same way right but but
I'm enjoying it I like I'm liking the
acting so far I'm liking the side stuff
I don't know where the overarching story
is going but I'm liking the the side
stuff animation we ain't talking about a
[ __ ] here again
there's a couple people that came after
King on Tick Tock over that video really
yeah yeah you know what I say right they
should have been there to vote
and that's pretty much it so last night
I was out with my baby yeah she took me
uh she took me to see for the final time
on Broadway family oh he was a fan
actually enjoy it he's a fan that's my
joint that is that I don't Cog did you
go on that trip with us I think I missed
that trip yesterday yeah it was it was
because [ __ ] and I had a teacher who
used to force force uh um opera on to us
yeah who was it no and I wasn't hunger
it was Miss rash rash yeah yeah she
passed away
so she used to force it on us and I'm
like I don't like any of this stuff
Opera Opera sir
stop yeah stop oh man wasn't that type
of party
was not that type of school
it's not a mission report not a Mrs
Robinson situation
Opera like real Opera onto us right
like you know when you're young you
don't want to see something yeah you
don't understand you have to read so I
hated that so it was an honor roll trip
that they were taking all the honor roll
students to to see Phantom of the Opera
once I heard Opera I'm like oh damn this
sucks I didn't realize there's a
difference between like Broadway and
like
progress I went and we were in the very
last row very very last row of the
mezzanine and I remember I love the last
straw
yeah exactly they give the kids a four
dollar the kids from the hood that was
that program where they take the hood
kids and we try to coach us yeah
high school programs
trying to get us out of that Loop yeah
look they broke the cycle we broke the
cycle
so we I just remember when that show
starts as a part where the chandelier
comes on it's like blow man you just
pyrotechnics and he and I was like yo
what is this and it it really just it
takes you away to another world for a
little while and I was like wow I love
this like and it was you know it's super
not up my ass not cool to like it back
then for sure yeah and I just I fell in
love with it and I just fell in love
with like with like musical theater and
stuff like that after it's very cultured
people if you didn't know yeah
Opera I think every year since that trip
yeah yeah I've seen it I've seen it ten
times yeah this is my tent
um and it was the last time I'm gonna
see it on Broadway because yeah
yes I did I loved when I helicopter when
they put a helicopter they were on the
stage half of a helicopter on a stage a
real helicopter I saw that I saw cats
are you gonna see the new Harry Potter
and we could have all of this on already
quickly I saw um the Harry Potter play
last year uh wow my sister uh some of
the best special effects you're gonna
see again yeah I want to see it I want
to see it so bad yeah the dimensions
were crazy the mentors are crazy yeah
all right cool shout outs everybody cool
shout out to everybody and of course
okay what's up I'll just say real quick
uh I didn't really mention it when we
was talking about r r but this Tuesday
me and King will be talking about the uh
Megan's movie yeah I saw it last night
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer
the prophet of Xbox
King of the statues with nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert move meant ooh
be loving and happy New Year Lord King
how are we doing sir oh man happy New
Year I'm doing better than Speedy
rashidi oh what happened with Speedy
shout out to everybody that came to
watch online with the Lords yesterday if
you did get a chance to watch it you saw
me yesterday
my bad I'm still stuck on because I'm
thinking about Megan um wifey was there
with me yesterday because you know it
was a Dominican fighting at the top of
the card so you know she had to stand up
for her brother so if y'all want to go
there and watch her with her tears and
her eyes
let's talk about the first place right
let's go the PVC gives the best cards in
the world the hell with the Zone the
hell with ESPN the hell with black
nation television whatever that was that
uh Bud was fighting on crappy card right
terrible card card I still haven't
gotten my 40 something dollars from I
anyway
um and I need to get the receipt so I
can send it to solve if I'm not gonna
get it back late please hit me up Black
Entertainment Television
all right so you had uh Booboo Andrade
is fighting early in the fight he was
fighting nickels right a pretty good
fight boo boo was out of sorts he hasn't
been in a ring in a while and he was
chasing Canelo for a long time but he
moved up to 168. he's looking decent up
there I think if he fight David
benavidez we can see him get knocked
move the hell out because he's nasty and
unorthodox right then the next fight was
Speedy rashidi versus this dude named
Villa okay and Villa I've never seen
Villa fight for the streets Villa he was
a hardened he looked like a hardened
criminal like a pretty hard and criminal
you're like you know the dude that's too
handsome you're not supposed to fight
the two hands yeah because you like we
made it this far he that handsome so you
know what he ain't getting touched he's
dead nice yo he he was a bully the whole
fight he bullied rashidi he chased him
with no jab he was Julius Caesar Chavez
and he did just like the Mildred tiller
you know how in the end we he knocked
mellow Taylor out yeah yeah same kind of
thing oh you just like impose yourself
what's up sorry Speedy but you need to
go back to the drum board Speedy lost
the fight by majority decision
um and then we went on to Boots and his
boots and this is the next Walter weight
coming up he was in there fighting some
new dude I've never seen before I had to
call him Karen because his last name was
janeza kick
pronounce it and I wasn't doing the
attic but boots won his fight and it was
good we got to the main car tank Davis
versus Hector Garcia from the Dominican
Republic it was every Dominican in the
world watching this on WhatsApp
do that what's up
I'm being witness I'm being witness
you know what that there's a combat talk
last night that you can
[Laughter]
and stop snitching
yo tank got him the bad thing about that
fight is the dude went back to the
corner after because I said he's gonna
get knocked down an eighth round this
happened in the eighth round going into
the ninth
dude said he couldn't see out his eye
after after tank hit him in the head and
almost knocked him out and then you
heard that he was having uh tingles down
the spine and
um and this is from a punch so wifey
sitting like nah the fight is fixed I
said so you want the dude to go blind
For Your Entertainment
Your Entertainment
it was it was a good fight tank won it
wasn't no felonious stuff going on I
know they saw some stuff happening in
the crowd it was getting crazy but dope
stuff I've been playing sonic Frontier
shout out to song Oh anybody who game
shits with anybody if one game share
partner purchases a game and doesn't
open it and download it right there the
next person the next idiot can come and
purchase the same game and you both are
just out of the money yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I did that stupidness with my
son because you know for the solstice he
wanted to get me a game you got me the
game he wanted
which was Sonic for the solstice I got
him the game he won it which was Sonic
you see the cell phone he got me
something I wanted it wouldn't have been
Sonic right but anyway he got that are
you feeling
Fortnight with the team how you like the
Sonic though how you like the Sonic
so far it's a PlayStation 3 game
developers don't know how to do the
water right I love how he said
PlayStation not Xbox like no no no
PlayStation 3 had a distinct visual art
style that is second enough for me I
thought they I thought they showed a lot
of round curves on the um polygons they
took it to the next level for me but the
rain looked like hard rain okay like the
razor rain with the okay okay the the
world looks Barren and boring the sound
of the sound of the music of the is just
the worst Sonic game that I've played
damn wow it takes boring to a level that
I've the controls is good but it's the
most boring blind it's it's like
of Japan made that Sonic that they
wanted to make this is it um no Sega of
USA involvement at all and it feels like
Sonic is just in a foreign land it's
just like I don't know this dude
yeah it sucks so bad ever born is going
to do something everybody
is not going to be pleased with this
sometimes you can sit there and want
something to be dope so bad with all the
signs in the world is telling you this
ain't it and I know it's it's gray
crazy then donkey have on it something
on it cloud in it crazy
oh damn yo it's if it's if it's a uh
it's a two star for me oh damn okay yeah
it's it's I would never recommend this
game to nobody
yeah and I'm glad Phil skipped it and
didn't put in Game Pass oh my Fields
give me wow wow okay that's that's a
first that's how he's gonna board The
Game Pass no it's not yeah I do not
think anybody should partake in that oh
wow anything I should be playing sir
that's it fortnite with attic and um
slow-mo and everybody else but yeah I
see you put the kills up no doubt yeah
yeah
well I can't look like a polar bear I
said let Eskimo King talk
hey look you look like an extra from the
Revenant yo nah he's been like one of
the nights
watches
coming they should not get past this
wall
the watches on the walls you imagine the
nice watch has sunglasses
yo that's crazy that's crazy anyway
and um
and of course we have the game in the
gym so this year why they gotta have
glasses on the water
the Sun is bright up there I can't
[ __ ] like it's like they forgot the prop
like like the um
your body forgot the Starbucks company
left it in the seats somebody said tell
King to hold the door
hold the door sorry sorry all right I'm
out of pocket
look like Cognito spread that really to
the road with iof not telling you what
you would eat what you need to hear
shout out to all my family plays we had
a good definitely do we came back as
well this week talk about Xbox 2023
catch that ultimate on all blasted media
talking about our top um five games
anticipated until the chat yo CJ what up
I see you really I gotta stop with the
lab because I can't continue my intro
because y'all keep me king with the wall
anyway
um get a shout out to that shout out to
Ashanti bottis
90k Road 90
000 subscribe together for Lord about
this by my co-host of the last World
podcast with tiger Travis has Carol 9 on
one of the ogs uh fun fact uh Scaro 9
actually had last four podcasts before
we became last one podcast he had this
he had the rights but he was like nah
man I ain't doing nothing with it I like
what y'all doing you know what I'm
saying so yeah he let us rock man we got
our publisher back so salute to him and
then um he was talking about what's
going on light fall like this stuff what
is King doing I don't know what King's
doing I'm scared that his his cameras
off
foreign
games and then Midnight Sun just took up
all my time oh that's what I was playing
sorry too oh you're playing it yes sir I
got Ghost Rider and I'm acting up oh
okay he's got the steel Souls mechanics
did you have to drink with the car with
the truth yeah oh that's crazy but um I
like the joint where I make little Pits
on the floor yes the drops and I can
throw people the Hellfire yo when you
get I'ma tell you right now okay you
such a comic when you get his Penance
stair card we were so close to being out
of the intro oh man but why see wow
and all this other stuff then y'all had
like six HBO specials
intro could have been over but I just
started
[Laughter]
anyway
so yeah beat Midnight Suns you know
because I was playing games
it's long it's long now it's a long game
it's a long game now I will say this I'm
a bit extra and I was doing everything
like the side quest I was doing the
Abbey stuff the spiritual stuff it's
kind of like Mortal Kombat to pick
there's a lot of Secrets and stuff at in
the night cycle on the Abbey outside of
the base grounds yeah and if you do that
stuff that could really help you with
the Indian the game is going to really
start to ramp up Captain America is
Beast Spider-Man is Beastie in that game
with the right deck he uses the
environment real crazy Iron Man is like
a very assessing character and he can do
a lot of skills balls but I will say my
most powerful characters Dr range is
insane in that game
um Spider-Man
surprisingly the the guy that you are
the hunter if you choose yo I was
getting my Storm Shadow on I got some
suits that I like
yo very good character that game is
criminally underrated it's three games
in one it's the combat game the
turn-based aspect of the cop which is
fire then you have the actual Base
building which is kind of X call me and
Nintendo and then you have you had a 10
mil that's another thing that's actually
four games because then you got the
tender relationship game you want to go
you want to do book club with blade I'm
gonna have a book club
yeah I like that because I did a couple
of things and it leads you to other
stuff like you find out interest with
these people and I didn't know like when
you build up super interest with these
people yeah they defend the fight better
and you start to get exclusive
um bonuses and cards and Buffs the team
um Synergy mechanics are crazy look if
you're a comic book fan highly recommend
if your Xbox fan highly recommended and
the story gets good like they they oh
damn I want to spoil the king they have
something so far they have something for
me
as a even though my man's not in this
game yeah they have something for me
you're gonna know when you get to it
just keep playing the Ghost Rider stuff
and the Johnny Blaze stuff because you
know Johnny Blade and then yeah so we're
moving so I got that um we're playing
Destiny season itself really good you
know I'm really feeling the story it's
fire they do some real cool callbacks to
that to the iron Lords and uh go check
that out and um I just started Final
Fantasy VII crisis course I gotta hit
addict up all these references and Zach
and the stuff that's going you need to
get into fortnite right now they got the
destiny stuff up always yeah I bought
all that stuff so but they got new stuff
okay no I don't I don't I don't know I
didn't buy it no doubt shout out to Paul
in the building oh yeah yeah midnight
Suns you already know what we do we know
what we do okay okay I see my midnight
sons in there kick set [ __ ] show us that
bill yeah yeah my my one of my decks is
crazy like yeah but anyway so I've been
doing that and um yeah I just want to
really quickly talk um iron bank a
little bit soft just from the um
Partners at valari just want to give you
oh yeah update you know what I'm saying
so so right now we may have spoke a
little early on the EU in the UK we may
have spoke a little early it's coming so
we probably you know saying that's going
to be coming soon but not just yet I'll
let we'll give you the official word
when those orders go up now anyone who
placed their orders for their pillow so
far you should be getting them in the
February early March so be on the look
after everybody because they are coming
they're in production is rocking the
salute to the support also anybody who
did not cop the link is tagged at the
top of the description use code iron or
50 off get your valari gaming pillow is
fire it's embroidered with the Royal
Crest of the Lord make sure you go check
that out so I'll do that and then I'll
show you I was gonna say that and then
honest thing about the pillow like this
yes
I love my pillow the way it feels
against my skin I can't and even on top
of the fur so even with a fur
it's
approved yeah soon soon to be available
for a coach with a Volari uh with
velocity trim on the side you can rest
your big on the Block
and feel the voluptuousness
it allows your beard to rest while you
gain a kid
so you know y'all know what to do around
so yeah EU about EU Brothers by UK we
comment it's coming soon I'm gonna give
you guys the official word and then we
will let Buddy get shout out good
friends and fly go check that out but I
did want it really quick uh serious note
um I want to send some love out to hog
law you know our good friend you know
friend to the realm a lot of people
um came across his content here for the
first time and I remember you know
fighting and I'm like man this is a this
is a gentleman who has not only the the
law background of the Acumen the talk
mergers and Acquisitions and corporate
law you know good friend and pure gamer
pure gamer so you know as most of you
already aware um hoglo I did have a
stroke recently
um I've been in conversations with his
wife shout out to Mrs hope Lord you are
a trooper you're right I love your
product positive energy we're riding the
whole out of a whole gloss so don't even
worry about that but I just want to let
everybody know um you can follow her on
Twitter you know at Mrs Hogle I'll put
the link in the description sometimes
she periodically posts updates as far as
what's going on also on his channel in
the community tab go check that out you
can find out what's going on but our
brother is fighting he's turned the
corner you know I'm saying he's come out
of the initial stages he still has a
long way to go but see things seems to
be trending positively but um it was a
wake-up call you know for me and a lot
of us just you know as far as how hard
we work all the things that we doing
full-time job all this other stuff and
it's a reminder you know what I'm saying
that we have to take a better care so I
had a good conversation with her on that
as far as myself because I'm guilty of
that I'm not the scale of Hope but as
far as the responsibilities you know I
had to check myself and as my brothers
no I took care of some serious business
that I had a mini scare and I you know
so it's it's a wake-up call but please
send some love to Hogue law and I'm
gonna put the link in his description
because she's going to give some call to
action stuff soon and hopefully our
brother you know has a full recovery
because one thing about that man he has
a gift he's one of the few that can make
law sound fun interested he's got that
stalk he's got that humor I miss him
brother please recover well we said in
all the prayers all the good energy
whatever you believe in and as he said
send your pixie dust you know what I'm
saying whatever whatever you got to send
but um says some love the whole Glory
man that is he's a pillar of our
community it's to the point now I don't
even want to talk about FTC stuff got
like a whole game here so I'm not
waiting until you know what I'm saying
it's like that so um salute to the realm
on that but I wanted to get that off but
yeah that's what I got solve any super
chats before we get yes sir
I got all these and I'm just looking at
these last two countdowns okay so let's
go from the beginning we got Matt
without fear 20 pound Super Chat sick
remember for six months happy New Year
Lords just want to shout out a little uh
my little brother Greg who bought each
of us a PS5 for Christmas wow shout out
to Greg salute so we've been Xbox
players since day one and been diving
into all these games that are brand new
to uh that are brand new to us love you
bro no doubt that's amazing okay then we
got Gerald Mack remember for two years
five dollars Super Chat oh hell yeah
[Laughter]
every man made with the response
I was muted
oh I hope he salute the Lord's happy
dude you're glad you're all back let's
get it no doubt thank you always support
we got West Coast family with the 10
super chat requenya
see you in June brother nine is stand up
that's all fight fan and my mind is for
our salute man West Coast IOP salute
doubt we got Big Mad Mo member for 29
months thank you sir Lord bronze Happy
New Year to you all shout out to the
Lords and the realm looking forward to
2023 let's go no doubt we got the homie
hargit Chaney remember for one year two
dollar Super Chat happy New Year here's
to a great year in gaming yes sir
absolutely fantastic year see him in
Boston all right yeah yes sir then we
have I put the crest in the chat for
Lord silver remember for six months with
Lord silver now John RPG know what kind
of games he likes RPG son he likes
action games
put more crusts in the chat for God's
Soul newest member of the realm we got
another one I guess there's another
phone that's your brother
okay okay continue then we got
Necromancer zail remember for 13 months
Lord gold here's to another great year
of IOP and uh anyone tried dying like
two after all the updates on DLC I'm
finding it very fun I haven't oh that
game came out I was waiting for the dude
service to get that you know
and we got face 23 BK and why 20 Super
Chat had my PS5 vertical since day one
launched no issues and Sony sold more
ps5s and Game Pass has subscribed
it don't turn on it can't have issues if
it's not on
he said 30 billion like he purchased 29
million of them
you got one stop it you're a fraction of
a fraction of a fraction of a cost okay
R Kelly like that interaction like they
they do they know the smoke is coming
back so yeah
we got uh Rayden blade remember for 22
bus Lord bronze 93 psvr two games in
development but connect sold 35 million
psbr one so five million lifetime so PS
gamers only buy 10 of their games no way
psbr2 outsells connect one that's a
passion project
yeah
I'm all in and I'm gonna see how that
one year of support we get back here
Braden blade they're too proud Super
Chat member for one year happy New Year
fellas May the New Year be richer oh yes
absolutely you as well brother then we
have Chris Jones five dollar Super Chat
my first live IOP ever welcome oh
brother Jones thank you Chris Chris
Jones
[Applause]
brother I gotta DM you with some stuff
cause uh yeah okay
here the streets I ain't gonna put away
from but shout out for where you from
yeah yeah
yeah they outside out there I was like
okay okay I see what it is so he's
playing dmio while listening much love
and respect brother salute yo bro we got
to get the uh DB we got to get that back
on I know you was dead that first time
but yeah we got to get get that back on
No Doubt
we got Raiden blade member for one year
two pound Super Chat any new news on
Lord Hogue my uh my my
I guess it was my love to his family I
guess
yeah it's all good Emoji I'll put again
the twitters in the in the description
if anyone wants to follow the updates
highly recommend Mrs Hogue laws or
Twitter channel so I just put our
account up there and then again go to
the whole YouTube channel and also check
the community updates because she posts
up there constantly with updates of
where he's at with his progress and
stuff like that and send some love and
then also we'll we'll get the call to
action slow-mo's coming for you said so
if you always miss my super chats
yes
I see if I can help out because you know
that slow mo what did I miss of slow
moves yeah this is something about Bucky
actually slow more I have to agree with
solve I don't see nothing that you no he
did he did and there was a minute ago
there's been way back yeah maybe attic
will help out on the young help out with
that because yeah see if we can find um
slow-mo's joint on the on the side I'm
about to drop a coat in the chat okay no
doubt no doubt but we will take care of
that slow thank you for letting us know
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do something
different I'm not letting these uh
these copy and paste people so one of
them is going to be replaced with a
question mark ah nice nice
slow-mo said it was a member chat he
said it's all good remember I can't see
it just say it again because I can't say
it yeah say it again slow we got you we
got you it was a but still put them in
this color I don't see it well I can't
find it in that screen because they only
show super chats
they're getting weird that's weird
because yeah it's not good it's colored
yeah that's why I get annoyed by like
how YouTube rolls like they they want to
compete with with twitch and they bring
twitch stuff over here but they don't do
it correctly right so slowly says it's
called Baki and it's still trash is that
it that maybe I sound like slow that's
why we forgot it yeah
because it was it's just straight up in
the regular chat it's not a member
is that was unnecessary
to color it in you you algorithm
s he said it died was after he said they
demonetized it anyway
what else you guys okay hold on a second
I'm ready to fight it uh THX 1138 two
dollar Super Chat Game of Thrones on IOP
Lord King of the Wolverine
Metroid remember for one year two dollar
Super Chat how's the oatmeal up there
King I see yes
the gruel sir we eat a bowl of uh a
tight Groove sir
type bowl of GrooVe then we got ready to
play but before yeah Tupac Super Chat 30
million PS5 and defective PS5 Time Bomb
waiting oh my God
them radiator heaters
then we got Raider blade again two
possible chat series X and S you can
trust the build PS5 new DMZ
every other week then we got Sith Lord
remember for five months Lord bronze hi
Lords this will be a good year for all
Gamers unless your system has internal
problems they really should be more
forward about it before it's too late
it's messy
maybe mid but Halo infant isn't anymore
it's time to come back been playing at
and Fortnight with King getting victory
royale's over the past week I definitely
didn't see that yeah yeah in color in
color it wasn't color I saw it okay yeah
but see the thing with me with the super
chats after I go up for a little bit
they're gone right but I I I got
everything from the beginning
no no thank you so we got you bro we got
you slow not purposely leaving you out
exactly let me see what's next we got
chicken Jake remember for 17 months Lord
bronze welcome back Lords can't go crazy
I've been waiting Xbox will be fire this
year you got him be ready chicken Jason
King got the camera chinchilla
as long as it ain't pink B yeah
King murdered a thousand chinchillas
I told people that what I was hearing
about that uh that Forge Mode that it
could potentially help bring that game
back from the from the ropes of death
yeah that force is fine we we did the
community yeah that was fun that was a
lot you know what and everybody people
that I've heard talking about Fords on
other podcasts they talk about those
specific uh uh stages
they love the chivalry Mario Brothers
they love that I spent like three hours
going through all that garbage to find
the good ones that went for us to play I
really do so his his like for something
like the first day of light you just
better be on his first date yeah yeah
after that yeah whatever it is
like uh it was good
remember for 20 months Lord bronze
assalamu alaikum my brothers
I listened to DD and heard you're
wanting to get married your first date
should be with me at the Super Bowl
hashtag Niners okay okay
I've been working to pick up these
tickets
Super Bowl [ __ ] like let's go where is
these tickets is he taking patches Super
Bowl listen man now shot the Brock party
in the crew you already know um
I'm not talking crazy
man let's see what's going on we gotta
see what's going on but yeah salute that
again you already know
[Laughter]
Xbox World Order hashtag xwo Xbox xx23
okay excited for this year and we got
Tom from Toonami remember for 11 months
Lord bronze lessons 30 million PS5 sold
and only the two million people who buy
the psvr two are gonna have games to
play this year wow
no no Spider-Man No Spider not no two
million buying that machine
uh-huh
oh attic put a code in the chat you
shout out to whoever got that got that
show yep yep I don't even know I put a
question mark it's probably going to
take those copy and paste Bandits oh
yeah yeah what's going on I see you I'm
sorry
no not shout out um yeah so we forgot to
do our uh these these giveaways at the
end of the year it's like a Christmas
thank you so so merry Christmas happy
New Year yeah I got like 20 codes to
give away yeah you're young boy yeah
yeah I I I'm I'm not gonna do them all
question mark some of them I'm gonna do
some questions but um you know I'm tired
of the coffee Bandits just get Snapchat
yes man yeah we gotta do something about
the cops
I don't I don't hate on the hustle I
just got to make it harder for you to
hustle
there we go put the crest in the chat
for welcome to Lord gold dragon heart
Yobe thank you sir Saloon right there
appreciate that
we got Mandingo mcthick five dollars
Super Chat quick question is King
wearing 10 rings and is his off our name
a pimp named slickback that's a
slickback I only got two rings and um
yeah yes it is
you gotta say the whole thing Like A
Tribe Called Quest I better have my
money man
this is crazy
yeah we got hold on I got jumped a
little bit
back yeah you see okay uh we got Donald
two dollar Super Chat another year of
Nintendo dominating incoming oh it does
switch gangs are they coming in let's
get listen man you know how it is
you can't tell them yeah we can't but
tears of the kingdoms come in
I had this dude on uh Facebook
Marketplace because I'm trying to get my
son a PlayStation 5 right now keep it
quiet
in the next couple of weeks so the dude
wanted to switch OLED and exchange by
giving him my switch because you know
it's not an OLED right I was like but I
got this though yeah he's like are you
open admitting to like pretty much
committing problems
with what I had I told him what I had it
was an outlet though but I told him what
I had time on Kings hustling moving on
we got Dragonheart yo remember for 18
months Lord coach hashtag peace love
life happy New Year gents 2023 take over
for IOP I'm back on social media let's
go let's get it yeah they took the band
off him yeah yeah he just came home
Trump just got pardoned oh man
let's go extremely proud of you all IOP
is home love you fam give addict his
flowers always The Golden Child not for
real God give out his flowers there man
for real for real yeah please don't
start calling me The Golden Child
yeah I'm gonna start drinking like this
yeah we I think who's the attic would be
lit doing lit though
like enlightened attic yeah like the
pictures that he have on Twitter like
yeah yo I want him with a silk shirt
with ruffles on the side
30 million PS5 sounds like they'll be
okay when the ABK deal closes yeah it
doesn't seem doesn't seem like they can
be foreclosed anytime soon I don't know
they okay staying at 30.
nobody's buying that Joy
the crest in the chat for the newest
member welcome to Lord gold
that's the homie um
that's my last word my destiny Brothers
views out in um gcx in Florida which
beat Travis hey yo I had the GoPro and I
ran out of battery and you're being
hooked us up with deposit we was able to
do it on the spot salute them yeah yeah
that's that's my dude right there inside
the circle
all right let me see we got the doctor
63. five dollar Super Chat beat Ragnarok
b-plus playing Vampire survivors s plus
plus
that is correct
he's referring to the rankings
then we have let me see okay touching
plants and bringing them back to life
yo what is attic doing this
yeah he wants to get out of the top he
want to get to that yeah what is going
on
this is where we leave yeah when you
leave the child unattended and then to
his own devices and stuff with your
credit card
we got one more for me Von Raiden Blade
Two Brown Super Chat no two more imagine
new Zelda game came to Xbox it won't
happen yes it won't happen that will
happen and we got Mandingo McStuffins
again five dollar Super Chat vampire
survivors is a game of the year has more
repay value than those bangers have more
time in in on BS than shh quietly got
War
oh my God and yet the actual person who
made the game has no idea why people
like it so that doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's officially for all
time in s-tier Game Crazy
phenoms don't really know how they do it
to just do it it just happens it's
organic
then we got hard to find five dollar
Super Chat I realized how weird I
sounded [ __ ] I beat the third wheel yeah
I was like okay but not my type
can I read this that's a little salute I
got you brother so judgment freeze over
there can I read this next one yes
please
yo somebody say some devil child
sounding
[Laughter]
time
control he derailing us right now yo you
got oh shout out to Johnny oh my man for
the best day of Godfather you got Johnny
laugh all right Johnny's laughing
uh you know oh he said Golden Child
attic voice Jason what they said Jake
funny fact Johnny is the person I test
this out uh Johnny you the problem okay
he came here because he knew he knew
what was about to happen Okay okay why
are you in black and white anyway moving
on here and we have bone team member for
17 months happy New Year IOP oh this
year brings everyone joy and happiness
no respect the original yeah
what's up then we got random blade two
pounds Super Chat all Xbox games have
more play time than any PS5 game
I'm gonna throw back a little bit that
we got Lord Metroid remember for 15
months Lord silver Metro time Prime four
Gameplay trailer this year prediction
not necessarily a release for 2023
Metroid Prime HD Collection would be
nice though yes it continues to be that
grub is on the on the line with this one
again
I do want to break protocol and read
this uh non-super chat
show up his voice shaming
I can't moving on with this I do co-host
I'll break Gamers
game I'll break Gamers two dollars Lord
Cognito interview Monday on outbreak
Gamers
throughout the web Dave so I could
outbreak Gamers man brother I had a
great time you know I don't guess as
much as I used to in my schedule but I
had a fantastic time on his show I guess
sort of coming out Monday looking
forward to seeing it brother of course
we'll get you to run soon but salute
that man really runs a good touch he's
actually he should do radio yo you
should do radio man
production values continue
just incredible guy two dollars I love
that I like that PlayStation 5 is the
best current console well it's the best
last gen console because all your games
PlayStation 5 is DLC
then we got the taco five dollars in the
chat remember a whole year ago when
attic tried to deny vampire survivor's
place as an S tier games the whole year
ago
Game of the Year Elton ring Good Times
Vampire Diaries is the biggest
Vampire Diaries
Vampire Diaries Vampire Survivor is the
biggest game ever you tipped your hand
yeah
[Music]
King this is your conscience speaking
anyway all right we gotta we get ready
you owe me ten dollars to protect
Cognito was black Captain America
Sovereign is offline Illuminati King is
prophecy of Xbox and addict is The
Golden Child yes I did my homework son
right now
are we caught up NBC we were caught up
in there
and I only see 216 likes y'all having a
good time we having a good time hit the
like button hit the like button it has
to love the children and the kittens
in Argentina some random course
when you hit the like button for every
like that for every like that you hit we
can pull somebody off that Obelisk
someone someone told somebody to say
star Phil hold on I gotta find that save
the dingles in Australia
they need to do the extinct conversions
bring bring back the dodo
whack
this is work
I got the ideal because I saw fawns
doing it I was like what program can I
do yeah absolutely I don't care he knows
[Music]
I do take the L out of it yeah it's just
idea idea anyway
moving on
Happy New Year to the Lords let's hope
2023 is better because with news like
Hogue law and ICU it's not starting out
good shout out to him get well yeah he's
on the men he's on the map he's on the
man which is a good thing and we got
Leroy is the master five dollar Super
Chat shout out to the oh my goodness The
Last Dragon look we're having a hard
time getting through these super chats
they blowing us up Happy New Year
gentlemen can't wait for a great year of
content and see box dominant okay okay
here we go and we see you hold on a
second jump me a little bit Robert what
is that reading blade and related Super
Chat PS5 equals remake station equals
PlayStation equals melt station oh man
all right we out all right we did it we
made it I made it all right a whole a
whole hour a whole hour yes yes and
there will be no poll to the end
[Music]
Lord bronze the members went the Lords
went on vacation last week and they only
got one job never gained never again you
lazy Lima Beaver you lazy lima beans
no they got a tree job
15 job man yes I remember that skit
salute Hollywood rules member for 11
months happy birthday thank you brother
Happy New Years Brothers great job by
King last night
so we all set we ready yes sir all right
let's go attic man that's all we got one
more let's drive by Joe five dollar
Super Chat we're running up these
Snapchats
they don't want can we start the [ __ ]
yeah let's get to the show don't they
want this time they spinning the block
three bit what's up
now we really gotta wait
let me play with your joystick five
dollar Super Chat happy New Year I've
been holding them back for two weeks and
now I'm ready to unload
s
whoa the absolute the master of innuendo
yes
let me play it to joysticks back yeah we
got rain and blade Three Brothers with
that oh you already read that one thank
you he made another one just saying he
made another one okay PS5 equals remake
station equals pay station equals melt
station all right okay okay on to the
topic all right so Adam gonna set you up
man I mean Central as far as this topic
robit Xbox game showcase you know we're
hearing stuff um I don't know which
angle you want to attack this from but
um yeah order of games or showcase
itself but this is your topic bro what
do you want to talk about
um so it does look like there's highly
rumors of a Xbox
event coming out you know even Jazz and
Ray and all of them they they pretty
much saying the same things uh so what I
really want to talk about is like what
do you expect for this do you expect
like an inside Xbox or maybe like in
that hyphen one or maybe they'll go
towards the same direction that like the
state of plays and it's under directs to
uh what is your guys's opinion on that
and I actually want to start with keying
on this one oh the king uh
what would you like cake for the Xbox
game showcase 2023
potentially oh the road map for game
pass this year oh you're gonna like the
poll question continue
um
you know everything comes out in Game
Pass so I just want the road map I don't
I'm not one of those individuals I just
look at everything logically logically
whatever they showing is going to be in
Game Pass first party titles stuff like
that
um anybody just wants to know what's
gonna what's their plans are you have to
look at what's gonna happen with um
uh the ABK deal which I don't care about
at this point no more until it's either
yay or nay so then you know what to do
it's like it's like a relationship where
you just keep saying oh we gonna break
up or we're gonna be together we're
gonna break up we're gonna be just
somebody make up their minds so this can
happen already so we can know exactly
what we're gonna do and who else we
gonna date and what else we gonna buy
that's about it because if it don't
happen then they're gonna go spending
money elsewhere if it does happen then
they spent their money where they were
supposed to spend it that's it just we
want to know what's going to happen with
the ABK deal but that's later on
whatever's in Game Pass Starfield red
fall
um
we know it's RPG heavy to be honest over
there I want to know what uh first
person over the shoulders uh a third
person over the shoulder story narrative
driven game we don't know that's in the
cut being made that's gonna release
that's it I just want to take away
whatever Sony does well and just put it
over here because we know they don't do
RPGs well so we already know Xbox got
that online we know they don't do first
person multiplayer Shooters we know Xbox
got that online all they do well is uh
third person story driven story games so
take that from them so they don't do
anything well no more and we just
control the whole boy Xbox have that
video so they can't do it well they can
do it well but they do it kind of boring
so I just want you know their type of
formula just with more action okay you
know that's it
scores it's the same 90 people buying it
foreign
question for king would just be like I
know you're you're big on presentation
in this format so about my follow-up for
you was just like how how do you want
this show presented because um you know
whether it be inside Xbox format please
whether it be Nintendo Direct style like
like all even Nintendo Direct style I
think Nintendo Direct and Sony uh jumped
on that same bagging with a bandwagon
with the Sony state of play they copy
what's successful I think Nintendo's
formula when they started their tree
house stuff was great so I really want
them to follow the Nintendo's formula
show the game
a little light talking in the background
very small developer segment you Just
Seen A Face you hear them talk about
their game a little bit while the game
is playing and go on to the next game do
not do the whole pop and Circumstance I
don't want to see a coffee table with
different color M M's I don't want you
man
no I don't I don't want to see that okay
okay if it's this presentation give to
the games because you gave us none last
year so get to the games I don't want to
hear none of your spin doctor crap I
don't want to hear you trying to make
nobody the next icon in the industry
just do your job show the games what
you've been working on save all that for
E3 I don't want to see no faces I don't
want to see Bill face
no I don't I don't because at this point
in time I just want to see games I feel
that I agree I agree at this point
um you know the only time only one
person I want to see Phil is he's got
like a huge
you know if he comes out there and I
guess I can understand if he if he's
like leading the show like he's opening
it up with it that's fine but it's like
don't come out there and talk about Game
Pass numbers nothing don't come out
there and talk about no numbers I don't
want to see no numbers on that board I
don't want to see how many Xbox how many
how many bugs are grounded with squished
no no I I want to see games games and
games and I think that at this point you
got to show up or just stay home shut up
you just stay home oh don't even come
outside yeah well just like you did
don't come out
don't come out until you here's the
thing like last year was what was it I
would say it was like a horrible year
but if you were just on Xbox it was a
rough year and it's just like you got to
make up for that man yeah you got to
show that star field
um you know I honestly feel like inside
Xbox is okay they just they need to
restructure it to where the interviews
is at the end of it you know they come
out they they they go over what's going
on they show gameplay and they say if
you want to see more in-depth interviews
we're going to talk about that after the
showcase on YouTube after the uh in the
entirety of the Showcase we need to see
release dates on all these games we want
the release dates
[Music]
I want everything from January to June
with a date
um
no no no
I mean I listen no I know things could
move around right in those spaces right
I'm gonna answer I'm answering for him I
don't even want to see a month I want to
see a date with the monster like I don't
want to see no months
no no June June 18 June 16 June 15th I
don't care well I mean if you you this
is the home stretch for every game
that's supposed to be coming out in that
in that first half of the year it really
is the home stretch so if you have you
don't know when then how many of these
games coming in super hot
okay I got questions for y'all and
that's just worrisome considering a lot
of these games have already been delayed
multiple times so that's my thing is
like if you're still coming in super hot
then again why even bother saying this
is coming out the first half of the year
if you're not uh you can't put a date on
it in January in fairness we all agree
2023 is stupid stacked oh it's stacked
and we're talking not only Xbox first
party we'll talk about third-party
Partners we're talking about Diablo
right maybe in the June we're talking
about we just talked about switch coming
in hot Zelda tears of the Kingdom big
link solve oh yeah link outside and we
know where big link do where you put
your release date okay next to somebody
but see here's the thing but they
already they already set themselves up
by saying hey this is all coming out
before June
here's the thing yeah regardless how
that goes everyone else is dealing with
the same thing too and they're not have
missed that but holy States they're
showing releases the kingdom have a
release date
release date does it have a day it says
maybe something hold on a second do they
have a month or they have a date that's
my question because my thing is I think
there's a lot of I'm not challenging I'm
just made this I apologize
so my everything got dates with them
so if I could I apologize my question is
now that you know that right now that
now that I know that as far as uh Zelda
and stuff like that and then the Diablo
like what about strategic placement the
only thing I run away from is link
that's the only thing I run away we're
gonna move we can't the only thing I run
away from is link that's it yeah and
it's like there's no strategic placement
when it's already there it's already in
stone it's already it's already a street
date oh no no no no
yes
we go the reason why I'm saying that is
Nintendo guys is gonna buy link
regardless it don't matter what's gonna
happen it's like you can't run from
something that's inevitable right you
can just only measure yourself up
against greatness so yeah but you can
I'm buying you can't
all right I was gonna say you can't run
from something inevitable you can like
well you can wait for it to leave the
room
Horizon photographs would like to would
have entered each other so you're
talking about a whack game versus a good
game
what I'm saying here is my heart don't
pump Kool-Aid
I'm I'm not scared you know I'm not
scared dudes like a lot of what I hear
is a lot of fearing dude boys will run
away from link uh stay away from I told
y'all before if you're sure about your
day Step On His date put your ten toes
down toes down regardless to what I'm
buying link anyway but I got game pass
so my drink gonna be pre-installing
while I'm at the store
and and is and what's going to dictate
me playing what is who's better for the
love of God
listen for the love of God listen to me
because if you strong about what your
belief is you go in there and you make a
person make a choice
um go in there you go in the store
visually you put your game up against
them visually
visuals that's real nice that's real
nice and there he said that's beautiful
in practice
people are gonna run away all right
that's what I'm telling you solved this
is what I'm telling you yeah you buy and
Link regardless that is true right you
playing Starfield regardless
it's just gonna fall down I'll say but
this is what I'm saying you in Game Pass
15 up to 70 dollars this is the fight
here okay okay your drink gotta sell my
joint gotta pre-install so 15 is the
barrier is lower going barriers lower
this is the first oh hold on this is the
IP I gotta break protocol my business in
here shout out to Red outdoor 19. he
said redfall is rumored on May 2nd so
the idea of Starfield releasing the week
after is absurd here's my thing here's
my thing do you got that in writing
don't do it red like that I'm talking
I'm not talking rumors so I'm like I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do that I'm not
gonna allow you to jump in and say look
at her don't no we know did you come in
it's a fight day if you want to come in
just tell them yeah all right so but
then you get me on his show
oh yeah
that if he stuff that you just said
that's a Maybe Might it could be right
sound like somebody's scared that's all
I'm saying give us a date like addict
said okay here's the issue I have with
that releasing on Zelda thing let's go
how are we gonna hold them accountable
for releasing on their own IPS of Forza
and Halo but we're trying to say he
should release on on Zelda like what you
mean like it's a thing like when Forza
came out and we was like yo give it time
to breathe we're sitting that's telling
them Yo give it on your own IP time to
Breathe No drop that on tell him
when they drop it drop that old see this
is the thing this is what I'm trying to
say okay
this is when your heart pump cooler you
hear stuff like that like you know scary
dude talk that scary dude
70 start looking at it from a logical
standpoint okay I'm not I'm not looking
I know you not see that's the problem
because because Zelda defies logic
sometimes
[Music]
so are you saying just to clarify yeah
the Zelda and Starfall coming out the
same day would not affect Starkville no
you bought okay
nah you out of here
okay let me tell you why it's not gonna
Zelda is going to do the numbers that
Zelda is going to do regardless it's not
one person that's sitting here saying
if the Starfield come out I don't know
if I'm gonna buy Star Fields right but
okay but it's all metric if the metric
is engagement the who's going to be
engaging that's the thing like if
everybody that got Game Pass that's fine
but how many people that have games has
to also getting Zelda exactly
tax season month
oh that's the factor everybody got their
tax checks about the month of the
Ballers
these dudes walking in the store saying
give me both we're kids
let me address it okay because here's
here's my thing
amazing
release at the same day no the best part
about the PlayStation dude is he tried
that and he got molly walk right the
reason why
all right Horizon got molly [ __ ]
they didn't have game pass the game
wasn't released as a sale and as an
engagement item it had one Avenue to get
to the consumer
Zelda has one Avenue
to you you're talking game pass you also
talking in your defense we haven't
started it's PC right right so PC is
also another factor and stuff okay
whatever you said the whole time yeah
pull time but shout out to the legendary
Gene Park in the chat
if Zelda I gotta break protocols it's
the homie if zeldon stuff he'll come out
next to each other Starfield is gonna
get Horizon in my house and it's gonna
get Horizon in your house yes so hold on
hold up you're just gonna go out and buy
it I'm telling you what I'm doing just
just to clarify King we did say that
PlayStation was stupid for not delaying
uh Elder and Rain not Elden ring um
you know so what what's the difference
hold up I'm gonna tell you right now
between them but what's the difference
is you're the point you're doing point
of sale versus point of sale okay if
Microsoft didn't have other avenues to
get you to come in our field then I
would tell you move the date
they have complete
I see a million you got a 30 million
head start on whatever uh uh um Zelda is
selling you have a 30 million Head
Starts
Zelda runs over Mario
you're looking at it from you're looking
at it from a sales Point standpoint I'm
looking at it from both of these are
massive games and we can only play one
right you can only play one no but but
King addicts defense you're acting like
everyone got chinchilla disposable
income to just do both at the same time
make a decision that's it I have faith
in the 30 million stronger since our
Game Pass okay they're already going to
download it okay
PC dudes that don't gotta switch right
that's gonna download it okay and buy it
I have I can't faith in the fact of the
product what I'm trying to tell you is
stop letting your heart pump cool
this is so big that you acted like Zelda
has not been dominating dudes outside
for a minute we just we have two like
it's not about running it's about being
smart you're smart like at the end of
the day not only do you have the Zelda
Factor right you got the fact that we
got Diablo close by and then once again
one other thing in your defense I'm
trying to help you no you got it you've
got you you've been through area but you
got your own red foil that you got to
decide where red fall plays it all is
you can't cannibalize red fool you gotta
let them breed too so it it's it's the
street all I'm saying is strategic place
but I know you call it scared but I'm
calling strategic places you have to
allow this game to breathe your other
first party game to believe your third
party
and big link
let's say red Four come out in February
okay
that leaves oh no but the room is the
rumors we're gonna talk about the room
is already saying no the rumors are
saying no no I don't care about these
rules I'm so sick and tired of NDA dudes
okay okay
I want to hear what you had heard and if
you can't give me a uh uh you can't put
your name on it you can't sit down on it
please shut up about it
you know the reason why is I heard a lot
too
I don't care about what you had heard
what I'm saying is we know for a fact
Link Link Link put his ten toes down see
you on the 12th yes whatever's good
right so if Lincoln tell you whatever's
good he has one way to sell to the
streets what he did he come on your
block he pumping tears he got a tear he
got a body okay so what I'm saying is oh
yeah of course he caught a body yeah
you're ready you're Horizon outside
lacking
what he came in lagging was he was
boring
okay but see this is the thing with
Horizon yeah Horizon stood up right next
to the dude that was pumping it had the
same point of sale uh uh options you
you're not gonna pump what to do with a
better product it's just not gonna
happen right so Horizon tried to post
stuff to do with the better product than
no name and it didn't work out okay
I know this is gonna sound like listen
listen
what Microsoft is able to do they're
able to post up right next to you but
they also have digital sales situation
happening over here and then you're also
using an Amazon situation for the PC
dude so you got PC you already got your
engagement numbers so all you doing if
the pump happens right there whatever
you get from direct sales is whatever
you get okay but you have more Avenues
to distribute than the one Avenue that
Nintendo has I'm not saying that is not
going to be a serious situation yes but
what you can't do is you can't start
configuring your timeline
of Microsoft moving for somebody else
stand up behind your products in your
defense I don't think they've moved
around for too many people they usually
come out I mean they've made mistakes
who who told them to release rise of the
Tomb Raider the same day as Fallout 4
whatever the heck it was it was like now
we own them they can't do that so this
is what happens when you earned and lost
we just buy the dude yeah Charles or
stupid Horizon they had that thing on
them that day
yeah
we don't break us back we don't know the
numbers that of individual gains playing
game pass but I'm willing to pitch
there's going to be more people playing
Zelda in those first 30 days than people
playing
what about attic is the Zeitgeist the
Zeitgeist and the possibility and the
possibility right that Starfield comes
out more broken than Zelda right and and
that Starfield is an unknown question
versus a known his historic with
reputation like for as much as I'm hyped
about direct sequel for one of the
greatest games
here's the thing here's the thing man
we gotta look at it from like
what's what I'm looking for
a like a content creator influencing
thing too because they drive a lot of
these cells they drive people playing it
look what happened on high in life yeah
high in life gone on Tick Tock blew up
that is true now you're gonna split the
consumer base probably into half and the
fourth some playing Starfield some
playing Zelda and as we've seen Zelda
will probably be everywhere on Tick Tock
it'll be everywhere on Youtube it'll be
everywhere on on Twitch I'm not saying
starfield's not gonna have some of that
of of that link but what I am saying is
that that Zelda hits hard and if you get
someone like like Valkyrie on YouTube or
pokemane or all these big twitch
streamers that are playing these games
they're gonna gravitate towards what
that streamer's playing and I think a
lot of them are going to be gravitated
that has a good fan base to tweet and
twitch out whatever Starfield is doing
it takes one viral moment it starts
yo if that Viral moment's gonna be Zelda
but high on life didn't have Zelda to
compete with like oh
you didn't have like high life was
essentially there by itself with the
whole time to breathe with the old time
to breathe and what many people consider
to be an all right game and look what
happened came out around
um uh uh uh God of War
um oh Sonic Sonic what happened Sonic
what happened
I'm talking about inside Game Pass I'm
talking about
I'm not going to compare direct point of
sale and I'm definitely going to not
going to compare a trash game to a a B
level game right
I'm not gonna compare trash to DLC I'm
not yeah
something with the level of of sale it
has you have too many options versus the
one option Nintendo's going to do what
Nintendo's going to do but from a
business standpoint you have so many
options so way many ways to Market you
can go up against it what I'm saying
if red foresee this is the problem let's
go everybody's moving so many things
like well what if this and what if that
I'm with attic give me some damn dates
okay so we can know exactly what's going
up against what because what I'm what
I'm what what sucks for me is because
company that I love the company that I'm
repping
it sounds like y'all listening to to
those who heart pump Kool-Aid oh and and
and it sounds like your hearts are
starting to pump something late up in
the building okay
what I want is I want that show to come
up okay what you want I want you to put
ten toes down I want you to be
aggressive like Sony used to be walking
up to people buildings talking about
come outside Mario so give me the
perfect show they come out and you want
the dates I want dates I want I want
fight dates fight dates okay remember
when HBO and show time you suppose
on their day purposely just feel just
just because because I want you to make
I want you to to make them make a choice
you have the ability
all over the place you have 30 million
in the bank 30 million okay want to go
up there getting the gun and say shoot
me
yeah but I have a vest on it look what's
gonna happen here's the thing here's the
thing
second off when it comes to that you
know Game Pass is going to be effective
but at the end of the day it's all about
who's gonna download who's gonna play it
and
hey hey Gene uh What uh G put put in the
chat how many Pokemon sold in a week on
the switch
they sold a week
did you do that do me a favor put that
in the chat how many Pokemon you know
not not Zelda sold in a week I want to
hear that I want to hear that was it 30
million
I gotta break protocol he betrayed you
he said
he said also Nintendo has he disagrees
and also the tenant has 120 million
consoles for Zelda Starfield is current
gen only so maybe 25 million consoles
plus PC uphill battle hopefully
Starfield releases that's a good point
yeah it's a good point look breath of
the wild is sold probably as close as
sold close to 30 million copies
I'm willing to bet you that that Zelda
breaks Pokemon numbers
10 million Pokemon sold in one week yo
Okay so so that's 10 million is it 30
but here's the thing you're acting like
all 30 30 million people they're
downloading they're not going to they're
not going to you see this is this is
this is
scary
and these dudes hard so so logic versus
fear so all last year hold on Starfield
Starfield not me
yo what's your movement yeah
Starfield all these Xbox do Starfield oh
I can't wait for Starfield yo we're
gonna drop it on uh uh what is it May
12th we're gonna drop it on May 12th no
oh I don't care if you're gonna get
engaged you gonna engage stop being
afraid it's just that I was never that
Kool-Aid dude you don't get to where you
gotta be by being a Kool-Aid dude I feel
you Starfield needs every leg up that it
can possibly get
every leg up
I be with you King if it was the sequel
to Skyrim coming down if it was Elder
Scrolls Elder Scrolls this is the new
baby you try to get the baby
Bethesda has a hill to climb and Zelda's
already on the top of that and they are
exactly they already got pressure
because everybody like yo what y'all
gonna do what y'all gonna do y'all just
came on for 76 what y'all gonna do and
this dude wanted him to throw a baby
into a wild body field and I'm like bro
okay saying is don't let that dictate
your your Cadence because this this is
the other side of that case let it
dictate your case let me know
what
you slip out past June oh no no you're
looking good you're looking good you're
looking good no you look good you're
looking good I I know from what I heard
yeah no no no no it's not even though
it's official let me let me know I'm
Gonna Give You King bars for this is for
boys
but that's the site currently right now
they updated it Starfield exclusively on
series X S and PC in the first half of
20. they put their name on it now
officially that so that first half is
first six months like you said remember
when we was in New York we did the live
show and King said if they not first
half like they told you then they're
gonna get a king this video you know
what I'm saying that's right on game or
Xbox so there will be hopefully there's
no this video that you planning and that
they're going to hit their target so
that's a huge sign that they put their
name on it now just comes down to okay
do they have a date to give us also I'm
going to ask y'all this um besides that
we talked about we're gonna get into
redfall later my question also is I know
we don't like talking about this but it
is a factor
the ABK deal right and if this thing
does
get concessions right or move forward
right and I'm looking at obviously
Diablo 4 right
and I'm looking at that's I believe June
6th right yeah and ideally one would
think if a deal gets done right they
would love to have that in the service
they would love to have that in the
service and they also a third party my
question is proximity because there's an
elephant in the room we're also
forgetting about which is Gran Turismo I
mean Grant to be forces
so now my question for y'all all three
of y'all is placement right yep now we
have forget scare talk all right valid
we we understand the schedule that's
that's the issue they got to do it but
I'm just talking about for the home team
themselves right not cannibalizing them
not exactly so what how do you hand that
because I had this discussion with
Maddie on Duke and I'm a little stumped
and this is not scared to I just don't
know how to handle it if who's ready and
what we hear red for the rumors are May
if star field is first half if before
and then we don't really know Forza is
this weird thing where with it comes out
we know for the most part it's a it's a
lot it's a quality commodity right so
you think start yeah how do you handle
that I'm cute
how was it shown in the show first it
was showing yeah yeah the ray tracing
yeah
well that's that's another thing like uh
assuming that this event is going to be
at the end of the month like rumored
that means they have February March
April May and that's all what and they
got more games no you have the month of
June yeah the month of June nah I'm not
giving that cop up man they they have to
the day of that of that event of the
show
and after the show Forza has been
released I feel like I could do that no
but they should have to the end of the
month of June right I mean I guess I I
get I guess that because they didn't say
to the they didn't say to the show right
right whatever you have at E3 six yeah
12 months so we had this conversation
around the time of Forza Horizon yes and
Halo right and there were two trains of
thought here right one was anything that
goes into Game Pass right one was let it
breathe right let them give them that
separation and honestly I kind of feel
like that argument went out a little bit
when we think about it because Halo came
out and it you know it was great
initially and then we found out that you
know that that the overline service
right the ocean was ankle deep
um
so the argument to let it breathe and
let Horizon continue to have its moment
and then give give a Halo more time to
to be ready kind of panned out but then
the other side of the argument was hey
once anything is in Game Pass it's just
additive because it doesn't matter when
it comes out it's all there and there's
no there's no uh uh Whatchamacallit
there's no price point that you have to
attach to it if you're in Game Pass
you're not saying oh I have to pick this
over this it's all just there right so
yeah I think though I I think though
when we were just arguing about Zelda
versus Starfield the problem is that no
matter if it's all there at the same
time something is gonna fall to the
Wayside in terms of people engaging with
it and you always want that Zeitgeist
moment for your game when it comes out
especially I don't care yeah yeah
especially new IP you want to be the
Talk of the Town in the moment that it
comes out right and you wanted me to
talk about time for good reasons not oh
stop it was broken you don't want that
so for me I do think even in Game Pass
even though I was of the of the mind
that the additive portion of it is is
most important because it's just you
give people so many choices right and
it's all different types of games and I
think it that that in in a way it just
allows people to pick what they want and
they don't have to worry about prices
but at the same time it we're human
beings we're already gonna pick one or
two things to play at a time and we if
we have three quality things to pick
from Something's Gonna Fall to the
Wayside possibly two of those things
fall to the Wayside so for me
I said you gotta let it breathe and when
when you say let it breathe I'm
surprised that we haven't heard of
anything
being a noun I'm surprised I didn't drop
something in January right if we're
gonna get this show at the end of
January I'm kind of surprised the rumors
yeah
so I I don't know but for me I would
like a a late January
mid mid March first week of April and
then whatever you would like Starfield
first if in a perfect world oh I don't I
don't I would like Starfield that March
that that mid-march beginning of April
yeah I think you're probably I think
they're going to announce whatever at
the end of the month if correct and then
you're going to get a game March April
May it may be June I think you'll pretty
much get a game every month
because at this point they have no
choice like they already made
commitments they already made promises
like unless they break those which I
would be against but as long like here's
the thing I'm against
being a game and like into June early
July but if it's star filled and star
feels good then I'm okay with that but
it's got to be good yeah the room is
it's good it's people right around
showing their build yeah it's good the
thing that I'm gonna say is uh allegedly
excited a lot a lot of times you you
guys misconstrued what I said right yeah
that's pretty clear what you said fast
I just want you to understand what I'm
talking about because I'm not I'm not a
fearful dude right a lot of dudes walk
outside with helmets on because they're
afraid Something's Gonna hit them in the
head not that dude you got that dude
okay but what I'm gonna say is y'all
know what date this is coming out don't
let that date dictate your board right
be mindful of it strategize around it
listen listen put things in place to
allow you to have an advantage going
through but if what you have on your
slate and you know your slate you know
what January looks like you know
February looks like you know what March
look like you know what your slate looks
like you know what deals you have with
your partners and you know what you have
to have in place what you do is you make
sure all those powerful influence that
does PC games those PC gaming dudes that
you know that's gonna be playing Star
field you know those deep diving dudes
you make sure that they get that build
ahead of time because Nintendo's not
giving out no bills to go
what you do is you make sure that you
cut them off at the knees you chop block
old boy from the gate all right so you
make sure that he's paralyzed right
there he only have one way to move in
these streets if you're gonna go that
way you make sure that you block him off
you use ninjas you gave him 50 million
in the bag right so you make sure that
Ninja's sitting down playing Starfield
game day one ahead of time making people
thirsty like look at the Galaxy I'm at
I'm sitting on this planet eating my
ties
or whatever
you got the money you're going you buy
these dudes they want to come up you go
do what you got to do that's where you
use your money for those dudes that you
want to build up and have uh um M m's on
and Skittles on a boy you do though
that's when you do that I agree with
that if you gonna fight them you fight
them as dirty as possible with as much
money as you can make sure that that
baby survive I agree with that because
expect you know even if a realm where
like Zelda comes out the same day buying
all the influencers and making them play
Starfield I know that sounds mad corrupt
but it would help it would happen
wow
you know what it is it's just Zelda to
me Zelda the only thing next to Zelda
that has that kind of energy is
obviously the King which is GTA right
you move away from GTA okay
you move away from God but God's gonna
do regardless GTA because I remember all
every year Battlefield dudes drop your
date on the album this is the one no we
ain't scared no one wants to do that
doing it on you doing it with one way
point of still you're not gonna beat a
juggernaut you're not gonna Slug It Out
with Mike Tyson they don't even got that
like Chicago should they say they don't
have the base that's the Nintendo has
it's dope it's dope here in a Kool-Aid
oh
yeah
you want to risk this IP it's a brand
new trip
just because
we Xbox
see that's all right so I just it won't
die with the level of Point of Sales and
what you're able to do to manipulate
everything is good without a history we
don't know anything about it but can you
assuming too many points of control
there that they're able that this game
isn't coming in hot right like you're
assuming that you have so much control
over what's ready when and when it's
ready and when you're able to drop this
and what you're able to do in the market
the thing about it is that specifically
this game
Zelda is ignorant to all that Zelda does
not adhere to rules I'm not telling you
to go out and Target Zelda and say hi
I'm here with you that's what it is
saying is if it so happened that it
falls in that month that you can release
it that you planned on it well then
don't duck the Fate oh okay and go catch
that word
listen I'm not gonna duck the Fate but
I'm gonna make sure I got something to
tip this fight in my favor okay maybe
that day yo your sneakers is double tied
maybe that day you got some dust in your
face
people's already clipping us and putting
us on Twitter like this I don't care
okay great no this is awesome
who is this the scary dudes scary dudes
is gonna side with y'all okay
it's gonna side with me
I'm with you but I don't need to take
that beat and when I know what's coming
like it's one of those things like like
it's one of those why am I gonna take a
beating that I know the outcome too just
because just learning anything this is
this is okay this is what I'm saying if
you got to go you got to make a trip
right let's say we gotta go to Boston
the Gucci's out there
with Different Strokes the goods
yeah yeah beat you and he said yo I want
this fate
we already going to packs anyway
you already got me I don't know about me
you don't know about me you may lose
this fight but he gonna know he gonna
get touched up
so this is what I'm saying if they had
plans to release that month this this is
the only thing I'm saying which I don't
think they have plans to release that
month that game
if you did and it so happened to land in
that month don't duck that fade right go
out there and make sure every twitch
streamer you buy everybody you can right
and you make sure that you attack them
in a way that they cannot uh they cannot
attack you backing oh
we got the Xbox two in the building
is this camera
uh impromptu appearance from the uh man
with the million ran down to a 19.
I asked Lee for the link 30 minutes I
didn't even know you was asking I was
too busy about back thank you it's funny
I was sitting there I was like I wonder
if he actually DM me and I looked like
oh my God he did
I ran what's in it
I love King's confidence
in this because a lot of people don't
have confidence in Xbox or any of their
releases me and Cognito talked about
this repeatedly yes I love the fact that
Kings out here being like screw it
launch it the day of freaking Zelda
perhaps the biggest game next this
upcoming year right I love that
confidence but King I think you're
fighting the wrong battle here because
you know what would be a better release
date what
June 22nd same day as Final Fantasy 16
give the middle finger to squaring
yeah star film star film quality Final
Fantasy 16. and you send a message to
square as well like you're not gonna put
your games on our platform and you're
just gonna take so much
you can have your you see you squarely
can Target uh uh a better franchise
that's been doing things you can
squarely Target it see what you just
told me is you think Final Fantasy is an
easy done you think they food
he's an easy duck compared to Zelda you
look at the dudes in the yard and it's
like yeah I could take that dude oh he
picking to choose it wait kick it juicy
I'm sorry win that fight well here's the
thing here's the thing Zelda rarely has
misses Zelda Final Fantasy Final Fantasy
is an up and down thing so 16 might be
amazing but it might not be amazing so
you you might catch him on an off date
yeah but you know I as me addicts I'm
saying do that I love that
[Laughter]
all I'm saying is
I think and and I know it's highly
unlikely that the game comes out before
that that that E3 joined because I think
they want to do a big thing with it what
I'm saying is don't duck the Fate if the
fade has to go down that's all I'm
saying I ask you this question because a
lot of dudes didn't believe in Phil but
I was sitting here standing up Champion
oh boy and a lot of you guys said well
I'ma sit on the fence all you fence
sitting dudes now want to sit in the
same seats next to me I don't want you
sitting next time
tell me an instance when Phil went out
there and just dropped bombs instead of
strategically exactly positions
right but what what what I'm saying is
from my position of Faith right so Rand
came in he said I love your faith I love
you standing behind X Y and Z I love you
not backing down right
I remember a lot of heart this
conversation must come out a lot for me
and it's that talk I hope they not
listening to y'all like I hope they're
not looking at your Twitter I hope
they're not asking you all guys oh for
yo what should we do type of thing I
hope they listen to some some dudes
that's out in the trenches that really
believe I believe in everything that
y'all gonna do okay I believe last year
y'all didn't come out with anything
right so the belief with me is oh y'all
was polishing up the stuff to make sure
it came out right I don't want redfall
to come out with any problems I wanted
to come out hitting hard okay I want I'm
on Starfield to come out and do exactly
what it's going to do I don't think that
you're gonna put it up against Zelda but
I said if it's gonna be that month you
stack the cards in your favor and you go
in there you punch the champ in the
mouth and you never know you might knock
oh boy out and tell them but if you will
never know if you don't swing first I'm
not saying don't stand there and take
surely knocks out Zelda if it goes in
there with no gloves on and and so Zelda
got the biggest gloves known to man some
cushions
okay I I feel you I would have been with
you if this was Elder Scrolls because
Elder Scrolls
that is one of the most dominant
franchises that's the compare that's
their established baby with track record
Zeitgeist and Legacy that's what Zelda
is Starfield is a new unknown quantity
because because it's foolish it is
foolish it's hubris for the sake of
hubris
that's what it is
Bill Spencer super smart executive does
he do that exactly ask Phil if he do
that we don't where the release date is
no he don't
let's say he get boxed in so he saw no
no listen to me
so no let's say the ABK deal goes down
he gets boxed in by now releases
you know you have these games just
released and now you boxed it okay let's
say your deals Force you in a position
well you gotta stack that you gotta
knuckle up right you know sometimes you
can't duck the Fate listen kids
listen kids this is Man Tall this is man
talk this is listen kids I told my kids
yo if you gotta fight don't look for the
fight but if you gotta fight I want to
pick up the winner I don't care what you
got to do to make sure you win that
fight but you win that fight and I'm
coming to pick up the winner if I got to
get bail money then I got to get bail
money but you make sure that I pick up
the winner I don't want you in a fight
and I'm picking up the loser so you
going and you give it everything you got
and if you tell me Daddy Listen Hold on
if you tell me Daddy I gave it
everything and I still lost you still a
champion but you do not go in there
talking about I don't know if I'm a
swing don't run your mouth you knock
them out you swing as hard as you can
you make sure that you try to win this
fight but you don't go in there as no
sucker
I'm gonna be honest with you
notice you guys are not Spartans
let's say that it's either release with
redfall or release with Zelda I'd rather
cannibalize my own stuff than fights out
he said he will rather
do that it's antagonizing it it is what
it is man yo slobo said didn't the 300
sport is done here they died but them
Persians knew what a war knew what it
was
guns over there
it's just that you got nowhere to pick
your battles I gotta turn my camera off
this is cool
listen man let me give my finished final
boss over I I feel okay King is he's a
man of his conviction that's why he's
the kick that's why he believes in Phil
he was the one that put his neck out
there he's the one that when everybody
was saying in his defense but everybody
was saying it's why I have his knees
right now
we thought Xbox was out of gaming in the
Xbox One era and then Phil kind of came
on board he was announced as the head
you know King was the only one that I
remember severely on the front line when
it was not cool to be an Xbox fan or
like the platform even say you're
associated with the platform so I'll
give him that you know with this
situation I want to get a refocus a
little bit then we wrap up on back to
the the show itself me purposely like I
agree with y'all they have to give
windows at minimum you know what I'm
saying now yes I saw them with you I
would love the dates I would love the
exact dates the time frames was when
they're going on I do also want to make
sure that we're clear on the format like
I really want less personalities yeah I
really want this is a base that's been
starving 2022 we know what happened the
first party AAA experiences were not
there you and you didn't show up at the
game award so the hunger is there and
the pressure is there right to really
execute and get people hype that this is
a new year this is different so to speak
so I think they have to do that I think
they have to show those those games show
them well
um I think purpose I think I also which
is interesting and shout out to you is
that I believe grub grub grub and
special Nick and them shout out to XBox
error I think they discussed um
potential a new IP could be shown you
know um I believe uh from uh Tango game
works I believe and um I'll shout out to
you Rand and James they also talked
about it on the Xbox too and um listen I
think I'm with King also on
somewhat of a road map you don't have to
have specifics but let's get an outline
somewhat of what potentially we could
expect you know so on some level I think
that'll be interesting and look
I do agree that yes the ABK deal does
play we got to see how that plays if
that happens to close it yes that
changes everything but the main thing
I've I'm always going to say like
Starfield is so critical to the point
where
I mean you can make the argument
ran I think me and you've discussed this
as far as importance and pressure on a
new IP this is probably the most
critical XBox exclusive Landing
correctly that I can't think of another
one this game I mean a lot of pressure
yeah this is the biggest XBox exclusive
since Halo
you can make the potential to be like
bigger than gears bigger than like I
can't even think of one that would even
compare yeah brand new IP personal IP
from Bethesda 25 years
you know you saw what they did with
Elder Scrolls in Fallout like if this
this could be a watershed moment for the
brand yes uh so it's like I get I get
King's enthusiasm of wanting to be like
oh you're gonna go after the bully on
the Block and the Zelda but we also it's
like
I think you need to release the game
when it's ready right is it going to be
ready by may you know um is it going to
be ready by June the problem
the problem you know we're all having
this conversation right because Xbox
said
six months ago or eight months ago all
these games you see will be out by the
end of June
right and we're in January and we don't
have any dates so now you're picking and
choosing and well it's like well this
you have all these games it's like well
there's only five months to left to go
and you don't want to break any promises
because you know because like they've
already delayed Halo a year right
bethesda's already delayed death Loop a
year and ghostwire Tokyo a whole bunch
of times Psychonauts 2 got delayed a
year right so it's like you don't want
this thing where people just look at and
be like Oh typical Xbox
they're just breaking their promises and
they did it to themselves nobody nobody
asked for them to come out and be like
we want a 12-month road but they did it
to themselves so okay they're going to
have to deliver and uh you know judging
from the Health page right it's they're
reconfirming that it's the first half of
the year which would be great the
question is there's not a lot of dates
left March is completely full February
is completely full
April's completely wide open but
everybody seems to assume that it can't
launch in April because redfall is
rumored to be launching on May 2nd
that's what Jazz has said Jazz has seen
hard documentation that that's the case
that redfall is coming on May 2nd with
Early Access on April 28th
um and there's like ones four is a
common so yeah everybody we have these
debates of like well what's best they
shouldn't launch games on top of one
another
um you know and they're in a tough spot
I like the idea of Starfield launching
in April which is why I said it is my
prediction I just wanted to be fun
because I think it's a little bit just
like yeah it'll be June June's you know
it's like we're like let's have a little
fun what if it's coming earlier and you
only got red fall in Maine you got Forza
in June
um but yeah I mean Xbox they uh you know
they let people down this past year from
first party even though Game Pass was
pretty damn good and third parties uh
were great towards the end there but uh
you know I'm seeing on Twitter lately
like the Silence from Xbox is deafening
and I'm about to leave and it's like bro
it's been eight days
you know like I would understand if it
was March or if it was even like Earth
like middle of February and they haven't
said anything I'd be like all right well
there's some cost for concern because
you have two new IPS launching you got
redfall and Starfield starfield's the
biggest XBox exclusive since Halo and it
doesn't really seem like they're doing
too much marketing and you have no idea
when it's coming right but that could
easily change they could easily this
upcoming week announce the Showcase or a
direct or whatever they would call it
for the end of the month right uh and
then actually please show showcase some
of these things like give dates like
that's what I think people want yes I
don't think anybody is expecting an E3
level blowout right because you're gonna
save that to June what people want is
like tell me when red Falls coming tell
me when fours is coming tell me when
starfield's coming when's Minecraft well
I don't think anybody's really saying
when Minecraft Legends is coming but you
get what I'm saying like show us some
maybe New Game Pass announcements
keep it 30 minutes like King said I
don't want to see no couches
I don't want to see no dudes just show
me trailers show me the things that you
you know show me those things if you
want to do those things in June be my
guest but just give me what you promised
for now people will be like all right
this is great this is what Xbox has got
and then we get to June and you can blow
things up even more like then you can
have the discussion about what's coming
in the second half of the year is Hal
blade gonna make it what about Hi-Fi
Rush right what about the wandering
Tower you know like what's early next
year is a vowed gonna make it perfect
dark you know or any of those other
things yeah so um yeah I mean it's just
I I personally I think Starfield is
probably a June release but just for
just just to be a little different I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say it's gonna
surprise people it's gonna come in April
and they're gonna do a dedicate I think
they're gonna do a dedicated Starfield
event oh and I think they're gonna do a
dedicated red red fall event I think
people could be dedicated for I think
they've hired the people they've hired
this new team to do these sort of things
and they couldn't do them before because
they didn't have the content now you got
the content now you got the studios you
have all these games bunched up if
there's ever a time to make it like the
like Star field as this major event that
it is or any of these other games it's
now
so like Starfield you you do an
individual 40-minute show with Todd
Howard and that's it it's just star
field you present it like so you you
present it like the event that we we all
know it's going to be right because I
think Xbox does a disservice when they
don't do it for these big games I think
that's gonna change I think get addict I
got some bars for red crap all right I
got a couple questions for you guys I
know we're gonna matter yeah because the
other events are pretty quick yes
um first off if everything comes out in
June and it does exactly what we expect
Starfield comes out it's great redfall
comes out great Forza comes out is great
and they come out they say 12 months
again are you okay with that at E3 yes I
am too as long as they don't break that
12 months and the very first time they
do it I'm okay with them doing another
12 months would you be so what if they
break it
would you be okay with them doing again
or you're saying no you already broke it
once I don't believe you I I'm okay if
they doing it as long as what the game
that they broke it for is not at the
event yeah I don't want it there again I
don't think if they break it the first
time they go back to that well again
they want to do it again because the
level of video that I will put out
will be epic ever approach that again
here's the thing like I think we have
gotten to
as long as they come out and they say yo
12 months we got hellblade maybe a valve
before the next E3 you know some of the
smallest stuff then the next year you
get it again then we got the other 12
months like I understand that we want to
be like we want a longer Road by it but
I feel like that's part of the issues
we've had because we've known about
stuff for years at a time and then we
start getting anxious on those games uh
you know if they want to do something
like that maybe do another XL this year
yeah you know maybe an EXO after E3 and
that's the show where they say look E3
is about what's coming out this year in
the beginning of next year EXO is about
what's coming out on the horizon past
those look I mean this is this is
interesting
on his prediction
it's time it's time for Xbox to do this
I've been I've been saying this for over
a year absolutely make your game seem
like the big events that they are you do
have the service by not doing it I I
completely agree and that's one thing
and I think I've had a discussion with
you which is like I looked at when you
know Sony presents like a ghost of
tsushima a horizon you know it's a
single event right and it's a breakdown
with the gameplay the developer talking
you're showing it and you're making an
event now I have a counter question for
this because I love that idea I've been
wanting Xbox guy okay I just want to say
I want to thank everybody in the poll
yeah
heart don't pump away from this deciding
with me yes yes they're siding with you
because their heart pumps Kool-Aid this
is an Xbox show no
um it's not an Xbox one
thank you and and don't tell him thank
you thank you
but what I'm saying is it's 200 to some
odd people uh what is it 300 756 300 and
some odd people uh took the vote
is down with that that poll I respect
you dudes 77 of people would would come
throw away the Starfield football
bless 77 of people would have just
sacrificed the the Starfield IP of the
ego it's really easy to be thuggish in
theory it's real easy to be Hood in
theory yeah
sorry [ __ ] sorry no don't finish
no there's no need to run home from
school
fair enough but I wanted to say that to
Red because again he touched my soul as
far as having Xbox doing kind of like a
dedicated show for these event games
right these games that we've waited for
right the red Falls Starfield the forza
my question is if you do that right and
that's the line and then we have the
show that's supposed to come up now
can you theoretically show it twice
so for example
a theoretic star field I get what you're
saying right so like like can you get
away
with not showing it let's say Starfield
and say yeah but we're gonna have
something else dedicated to you can you
get away with after the weight
and the the the frustration that you
even said yourself ran a lot of people
like yo they better show it's been eight
days bro what's going on like people are
thirsty for the knowledge of these games
and when they're going to release and
the impact they would have are they
afforded even more time to wait for a
dedicated well okay so you're saying if
they have this show at the end of the
year right but Starfield doesn't show up
but like they say hey we gotta we got a
dedicated show coming later coming next
month I think as long as they
uh message it right I think people
wouldn't care as long as it's not a long
wait or if they're just like if it's
like hey thanks for tuning in but tune
in a week from now to watch the
Starfield Showcase with Todd Howard and
get the release date people will be like
all right cool I got something to look
forward to next week and you know how
the internet go well I know how you're
gonna show it there's something wrong
with this game I actually have to
disagree if you show Starfield it has to
be with that release date I don't want
it I don't want no oh we don't have what
you want today but we have it next month
well like people gonna say we wait again
[Music]
said if they give you a specific day
like hey we just gave you a little taste
of this next week you're gonna get the
release date Todd's gonna talk about I
mean this is a big game this game a lot
of systems a lot of different things
like if you really want to explain it
the way he's supposed to you're gonna
need it it's gonna need its own event I
don't think just glossing over it with a
release date in in a 30 minute
presentation is going to do it so I I
don't mind that now if it's 100 right
say that if they say that and we'll see
you later again don't here's the thing
though we'll see you soon
we have been teased twice with this game
it's been delayed after we were teased
once you needed to tell me that you're
okay with the coming on that stage you
get like I'm gonna tell you wait longer
yeah
today but next week we got you I will
give them the smoke if they don't make
this June deadline that they imposed
upon themselves but I was say this
always I don't care if all these games
are delayed if you you Xbox is not a
position to come out with games that are
busted broken or not good yes agreed I
don't if they have to renege on
everything they've said for these games
to come out the way they're supposed to
I don't care if they all come out at the
end of the year I'm gonna be honest like
it just
they're not in a position to get away
with releasing subpar products I can't
okay okay my mindset is just like it'd
be different if it was like wouldn't
delayed we haven't seen it for two years
at E3 no if I see Starfield on that
stage and it better be on that stage you
better give me a release date you can
give me that yo here's the release date
next week we're gonna do a deep down
okay that's fine okay well you have to
show me what day that's coming out
that's what brand said yeah for sure you
if you give me the date and be like hey
next week we're gonna go we're gonna
give you the date you're gonna get a
deep dive sure if you just say hey see
you later in the spring and no star Phil
show up
um
they need to do that because like soft
said like
Starfield needs that 40-minute video
from Todd explaining everything I need
the leather jacket redfall needs a
40-minute like look at look at all the
talks surrounding redfall bro everything
is basically we should literally
everything is basically yeah
everything about redfall is basically yo
it's not this song
we're still gonna get the Sony topic but
being that we read falling right now
let's just ball right go right into if
y'all don't mind
yeah so like guys right you just get
your balls like I I'm super excited for
redfall because Arcane is an incredible
developer but you do have to say that
there has been a
breakdown in the marketing of this game
because ever since the reveal trailer
everybody's just like oh it's left for
dead clone oh it's left for that clone
oh it looks like back for blood oh it
looks like this and they've kind of
minimized what the game is right because
we didn't really see the gameplay and
even when they showed the gameplay this
past uh E3
it was like okay it looks it looks
really cool but the fact that they're
doing interviews now and the the
Articles literally like it's not back
for blood matter goes to show you just
how poor the marketing has been for
redfall when like you're leading with
it's not this game it's this game right
um but uh yeah the article that came out
was uh got me incredibly excited yeah a
lot of people are talking about
everything but this is what this is why
they need to do these things this is why
you have to do this 40-minute redfall
show and a 40-minute star field show and
you know because you're not gonna have
the time to convey that in a
three-minute trailer right so that's
that's why we've been pushing for this
for a long time Cog right absolutely you
know and yeah and it's about time maybe
they deliver on it no absolutely I agree
I wouldn't I want to get solved to set
it off because I know this was this was
his topic as far as you know the article
you get a chance to check it out you
know what's your thoughts on the new I
fall info when I came out I mean I think
bran hit it right on the nail on the
head like it's they've done a disservice
to this game up until this point because
none of this information has come out
through their own channels and I think
for a game like this you can be
secretive about a game that like that's
a known quantity already that people
have expectations for you you can't
really do it with this you really need
to give this game all the spotlight that
it kind of needs in order for people to
understand what it is so if you look at
like a death Loop coming from Arcane
death Loop was the simplification of
immersive Sim elements to try to make it
more palatable to more people this is
taking that and saying okay we're going
to take the immersive sin we're taking
to take everything that we learn from
making games like System Shock and prey
and thief and we're gonna blow it up and
give you a world the size of Far Cry and
let you play in this space
while eliminating the UV softness of it
of of opening up the map and seeing a
million things to do it's gonna let the
gameplay be emergent and you go out with
your team or by yourself and then the
world all of the sort of uh the World
building that happens within this in
storytelling within the world and the
NPCs and that all is what's going to
tell you the story and that is the
essence of immersive sin and emerging
gameplay it's about you going out there
taking the tools that you've been given
and then just figuring out weird ways to
approach all your objectives in this
world and by saying that it giving me a
world that that's likened to a far cry
but allowing me to just go in and figure
things out on my own and and and then
enveloping it in this sort of very
Stephen king-esque sort of uh Salem's
Lot sort of town and with a lot of
Personality because it one thing about
each of the worlds that that uh that
Arcane puts together they're very very
unique worlds with you know their own
sort of backgrounds and lore and that
very interesting characters and the
circumstances are always super
interesting and this doesn't seem like
it's any different so all the things
they've talked about like it it just
really like ran said it's been a
disservice up until now because people
thinking it's just a co-op shooter new
weapons a Left 4 Dead maybe hero like
shooter which where you know each of the
different uh players has their own
abilities that they bring to a almost
like a Left 4 Dead maybe slash sort of
OverWatch type thing where everybody has
this sort of uh abilities and it's not
that at all and I'm just
I was excited for this already because
it's Arcane and I love I love Arcane
games I love prey I love Dishonored
um this is taking this to another level
because I think like I said with death
Loop they try to simplify it to make it
more palatable and for a lot of it hit
for a lot of people still
no Maddie and Maddie the big Arcane guy
I understand his argument I completely
understand his argument because it
dumbed down some of the things that as a
person who loves playing immersive Sims
and playing around and manipulating
these worlds it took some of that away
from you because it gave you it framed
it in with a time thing right right
this is not that this is go out and play
find figure out what's going on
um I I don't man this this hopped over
oh oh wait wait yeah I mean again you
know you know my way is about Garfield
oh no I gotta come back at you because
you're the single player selfish
experience yeah you can play this single
player you can't you can't buy yes I
thought I I'm surprised because I
thought as the immersive single player
guy that Starfield with morgue lead to
your sensibilities and the fact that
this had a Cooperative mechanic that I
got your kid that that
um this would not that you would be
interested but you would shy away from
it and your your pure stealth guy that
likes to murk around in the glass and
you know so and this allows me to do
that with the single player so that's
what got you okay that's it yeah and
he's a graphic [ __ ] you know
doesn't hurt I'm surprised by that red
I love these type of games bro the
immersive Sim aspect of any game like
really it elevates it for me and if they
do it right arcane's a masters of that
Masters prey is a criminally underrated
game uh Dishonored still criminally
underrated
um they are masters of that and with
each successive game they've only
continued to hone that now to for them
to be like we're ready to apply this to
a massive open world with Hub elements
too because it doesn't exist a lot of
density at all density and when I've
talked about what my worries with
Starfield are is a lack of density in
favor of that broadness oh because your
skin goodness you're scared that maybe
Starfield may be potentially doing too
much from a too much from a school right
standpoint like school but I'd rather be
given super detailed uh environments and
abilities to do things within a smaller
as in a smaller space right so I just
man it kind of today it feels like this
could kind of be their magnum opus like
they're really they're not afraid to
apply everything they've learned to this
because it's scary when you think about
all the systems they allow you to mess
with right it's scary when you say okay
mess with this in this huge world and
all these different factors could come
into play right except for when you sort
of isolated something smaller like prey
or something like that where you have
more control that's why it's why Zelda
was impressive to me and people were
like oh those immersive synonyms like it
basically because when they give you all
of these sort of uh elemental powers in
Zelda and you could mess around and play
around with things it's the first time
you could do that in a Zelda game and it
makes the world that much more
interesting even though the world if you
really think about it apart from Big
landmarks in Zelda isn't super populated
right right
ah I'm excited all right
I'm excited because we've been uh
patient and King I don't even think they
want to get their balls off with this
whole redfall situation especially added
because
I'm curious because you know when
they're saying they're going out of
their way and saying this is not left
for dead which a lot of people thought
it was going to be like a Left 4 Dead
clone and now they're making these other
comparisons like with these games like
how do you feel like when you hear like
oh it could be more like Far Cry or you
know what are you feeling at because
these are your type of games too
perfect uh no uh I think that you know
I'm interested in redfall but it's not
really gained my engagement like that
yeah you know they say you could play
this as a single player game you know
um Resident Evil 5. you know they said
that about that too uh so it's just like
well I'm not saying that you can't play
this a single player game and I'm not
saying that you know people are wrong
for not wanting to play the single
player game but it just felt like I
don't know about you guys like the first
year year and a half of marketing this
game
they were kind of like marketing as a
multiplayer Co-op type of game and then
just randomly it comes with well you
could play use a single player game too
you don't need all the people and and
part of me felt like they're kind of
like
they're kind of like reading between the
lines so it's technically all like I
can't really like a single player but
you know I feel like they try to flip it
on its axle because there was so much
criticism on a lot of people thinking it
was a co-op game first right and there's
nothing wrong with that if it's either
one but to me I feel like there's a
little bit of a mixed messaging when it
comes to the marketing and I that's one
of those things that I might have to
just see exactly what kind of quality of
the game is before I jump out the window
I'm gonna play it I'm gonna try it
because I'm a fan of Arcane and I was
kind of like not necessarily the same
situation with something like that don't
buy it
no why
oh God because it's on gameplay
he is so I'm just saying you're going to
engage regardless he's so petty and I
wouldn't release it the same day
but but but this beat Starfield for you
so please be quiet
I personally feel like when it comes to
something like this I think this game's
gonna kill a lot of people I'm just
curious if I'm going to be one of one of
them so sorry
it just like I like what I see and every
time they talk about you different more
circumstances like there's like pretty
much like ascended Realms kind of that
that's like in like in uh Destiny
something similar like that like where
it's like a realm outside of the thing
and I'm cool with stuff like that I just
got to see more in terms of it's like
it's like people it's a loot shooter to
some degree yeah
with different attributes and a little
Destiny on a gun yeah I just I just got
to see how well it's implemented I gotta
see how well they did it uh right now
the one that I'm I'm definitely more
excited for is star that's what I was
gonna ask and I still don't want that
game to come out on Zelda we understand
we got that let's lock folk the
chinchilla oh my question
is a follow-up why are you more still
because so I'll flip the script orders
oh what I had always said this about I'm
learning I'm sorry I did not know that
yeah you know me and my feelings I'm
sorry let me be quick about because now
all the Todd Howard games have taken
elements of immersive Sim and that's why
I love those games as well because you
go in there you do kind of whatever you
want right you go in there and they took
that and put that into an open world and
again it's it's it isn't
it isn't limiting mechanically it's
somewhat limiting as to as opposed to a
Whatchamacallit an immersive system that
gives you specific powers that you can
manipulate in a world where the the NPCs
and the things that you're doing in that
world don't have the same abilities that
you do right
um
so it's it's they've taken a lot of what
I love about immersive stem and put them
into Todd Howard bgs game that is 100
sure it just to me
when you've seen the sort of trajectory
of BTS games and how they can be a
little broken and this that the other
to me I look to the masters of the genre
Arcane and Rose past God no
because of what they're TR as an
immersive Sim Studio they are the
masters of that type of game plan okay
and for me the Pinnacle of that reaching
the Pinnacle of that with how much
they've done to meet Todd scared me when
he's like oh I want this huge I want
bigger and more as opposed to what's
going to happen in the smaller spaces of
that game and that's what scared me
about what Todd wants for Starfield okay
no no shout out to them let me break
protocol just real quick I gotta give it
right back to you at it shout out to
Legendary hip-hop game is in the
building yo CS was crazy selfish yo I
see you out there doing your thing
brother sir I ain't lost all day for
Life yo I miss y'all we're going to see
you we know we're gonna see you in the
events brother E3 I want to go back to
you
um tell solve why we're more excited
let's start film and you'll follow up
why do I get a hint okay I'm shocked I'm
really shocked today but I I feel your
asses though I feel your answer yeah
good too I I just feel like starfield's
more of my alley because you know I'm a
huge fan like Skyrim is my all-time
favorite game so you know I I tend to to
lean more and I'm an arcade fan I play I
beat that flute uh I didn't play I
didn't beat prey but I beat both
Dishonored so I've played plentio of
arcade games uh it's just when it comes
to the type of gameplay I generally do
lean more towards to the fallouts the
Skyrims the Elder Scrolls watch Elder
Scroll is Skyrim those type of gameplay
and you know I'd like to see I'm more
Curious on seeing how bethesda's
software Studios is going to handle
bringing a type of game like Fallout
into you know a space type of uh scene
then I'm excited about how arcane is
making a co-op shooter from from
something like death Loop or something
like Dishonored I don't know that's fair
I I understand I'm the mindset kid
you've been extremely patient I'm sorry
let's get to you brother like red for
these new details I'm very curious about
you where you stand on this game also
now that they're saying it's not like
Left 4 Dead Guy you know what I'm saying
and it's you know more like these other
games and then obviously the comparison
of which one you're more excited for
between this and stuff well I know
um
they thought that okay attaching
themselves to left for dead it's a great
thing left for dead has has a ton of
great memories for the people that fell
in love with the the franchise and that
are still playing the game to this day
right uh left for dead people are very
very honed in on that formula and that
formula really works so when they came
out with evolve I felt kind of flat when
uh back for blood we saw that it was
supposed to be like laughable
yeah I fell flat
um that aliens game like aliens marines
that fell flag uh what was that that uh
the the game they just did it was so
terrible the the the dinosaur game all
extinction something something crap yeah
that was supposed to be like uh left for
dead
all these games fell flat
so it's you start to smell a stink in it
So when you say it left for dead you
know it's it's a small tight box that
you you have to hit that Target and for
some reason people can't either uh lock
down the feel of the guns lock down the
feel of Detention of the world they just
don't get it right right now you're
having this game associated with that
looks great 4K 60.
and dudes like yeah I've been left for
dead but there's a lot of Left 4 Dead
would be beaters that are left in the
dust it's like Destiny every time it's
always supposed to be some game Destiny
and it just never lives off to it for
whatever reason the streets are filled
and littered with this soul
not gonna do like scoring
and just have everybody think how storm
was supposed to be something else and
when we got it we was like oh
nasty right because I don't care what
y'all saying scoring look good
aesthetically but really though it
wasn't really the scary shooter game you
thought you was gonna get not at all
right so these dudes are really trying
to tell you Hey listen
you could play it this way we're not
this we're not like this we have to
explain what this game is because if you
go in there feeling that it's going to
be left for dead and it doesn't reach
those lofty expectations
it's gonna be a six on Medicare
so it's gonna fall to the floor so what
they're doing is telling you what to
have your anticipation set for where
where you're supposed to be now I said
this when when I win an attic to say is
he gonna buy the game yes
there's another attack from the King
letting you know that you're gonna
engage regardless why because you have
this service why you're gonna download
why because it doesn't matter it doesn't
what else is around it you know what
king
the reason that I'm gonna let you sell
um
the best part about you having my knees
is that's the realest thing in the house
your knees are shining in this house and
the reason why I can say this is is
because anytime I try to get back my
knees you're so scared to take that
Faith right
I'm gonna draw I'm still a king
everybody's gonna remember your name
yeah and that that's all cute and dandy
and all but at the end of the day I have
your knees who do I got a game
he picking with his release date on the
top of the temple like like wanting them
back and I'm like I'm already up there
listen I don't want them back because
without my needs I'm still knocking
people out
of your knees so maybe you can stop
running from the fight
look that now that you've got your bars
up hopefully yeah I'll just finish it up
look I'm excited I think it's I think I
agree with Rand in the sense that this
is why it behooves
Xbox two do these single game showcases
at some point because there's no reason
why we should be running with narratives
about a game and the developer don't get
a chance to express what the vision is
themselves right this is why so now they
finally came out and said no this is not
a Left 4 Dead you know kind of kind of
situation this is different you know in
this open world we got the density there
you know look I'm all about vampires the
whole vampire Hunter thing I think
that's cool the fact they said look this
world is fully explorable you know on
foot and stuff like that so that like
it's gonna be whips you're gonna be
going across I like that because I don't
want
it's so big
that you lose kind of like what's
obviously like you lose that that
immersive that that density that that
really tight-knit kind of you know
really engrossed in the world feel
and um I thought that was cool I mean I
do have one or two concerns about it you
know obviously I'm a co-op guy you know
they're doing the Overworld aspect from
my understanding is once you pick your
character you are locked into that
character for the whole thing so it's
it's drop and drop out but not from a
selectable you know if you pick one of
them you're gonna stay with that one now
I did hear like say for example so if
you if you playing with me we can pick
the same character but I'm locked into
my choice you locked into your choice
for that playthrough and the the thing
and I gotta see how they handle it
because I don't want until I experience
I don't want to go too hard on it one of
the strengths that I think I really like
of grounded was that open server kind of
feel at it I mean we would play and it's
like hey if addicts not playing today
you know I can still go on I can
continue as opposed to we need all four
of the homies you know what I'm saying
all the time and I want to see how that
goes and I get it because it's story
based you know you probably can't one
can't go too far I understand probably
this technical mechanics today
Borderlands does it just fine though so
that is true I mean there is other
developers that do it just fine so I I
mean maybe it's maybe they're doing
something different that other people
don't do that's a possibility yeah so it
could be just the way they're structured
in ways different than how how their
Story Goes you know it's just different
I do like the ideas with the weapons
that have the different attributes they
talk about like you know you pick up you
may get a shotgun that has these
different blows up fire and does it
while King has another type of shotgun
that does whatever whatever I like that
what really got me excited Ryan I don't
know for instance is that
I love that they said we're working
Within
on this gun play
that's what I want to see from Xbox game
studios as a whole if you have yo we
doing water on our game let's get CD Red
what's up I've seen that like I want
that level of synergy and Xbox games
through this but it's clearly some of
them have specific strengths and we know
it you know what I'm saying we know what
they do God but that's actually been
doing that for a long time right because
I remember in the uh it was neither The
Evil Within two or this last game that
came out that uh people at it actually
made some of the monsters like some of
the Demons or something like that so
they've been doing that for a minute I
love that Bethesda does it and what I
want is more of that from Xbox game
studios when you have all of these
creatives in the building so to speak
the same house let's collaborate hey how
did you do that and that gives me
confidence in the gun play because for
my understanding solve you know I'm not
saying it was weakness all the time in
in their games but that's something that
clearly they could improve upon right so
yeah was it was more the melee stuff and
like and Powers right they're very good
at that stuff but again yeah I love the
fact that they said hey we need help
with this yes because it's more shooter
than anything else right it's more
shooter it's and that's where they take
you know they this is what worried me
initially about this so if if they were
going to make a more palatable game and
death Loop were they going further in
that direction with this game right or
coming back more to their roots and they
kind of it seems like it's the middle
ground was I'm going to give you
improved shooting and we're gonna also
give you all the stuff that we're known
for right and for me you know it's two
things that I'm still excited about the
game obviously the setting the vampires
I love that they mentioned environmental
like killing and using environments to
be creative I love always love when
games do that you can get creative with
that you know I love the the fact that
people have separate abilities and they
have that identity I think that's cool
and the last thing I said is that I want
to know what you feel in this round
before we wrap up on this topic was um
they seem extremely bullish about Game
Pass
and I thought that was interesting
because based on their history I think
you could make the argument that arcade
has these great games but they not
necessarily Market it the best
and yeah right and I feel like this they
seem to be making it a point to be like
hey this is important for us to get
these many eyes like to King's Point
right you put into this service and
we're gonna get these eyes we're gonna
get this feedback that we're not used to
because it's such a base and this is
what king is kind of alluded to so I
wanted your thoughts on that Ram before
we move on is that like what's your
feeling about them in that spot now that
they're released and they even mentioned
like the pressure right of of yo we
gotta make this thing shine because this
is our Game Pass debut so to speak right
we we got to get these out like I was
curious what your thought process when
you you saw that part I don't know if
you caught that in the interview yeah
yeah I mean the idea of like oh how many
they're like man how many people are
gonna be playing this day one you know
we're gonna have enough like servers
available because you don't want any
sort of tech problems you don't want
people to play it in Co-op and then they
can't play or you know stuff like that
but the idea of and I like this because
Saab will agree with me
Arcane is underrated by most people
because most people don't play their
games extreme right Dishonored one
Dishonored 2 are incredible but nobody
really talks about them pray was amazing
but nobody really talks about prey yeah
that flute was maybe the first time that
they got a lot of um awareness mainly
because the reviews were high it was the
PlayStation exclusive I mean every
single PlayStation event from like 2020
to 2021 death Loop was front and center
yeah in their in their little videos so
a lot of people really don't understand
the magic of Arcane and the type of
games that he says because he's right
maybe if Dave was so he's like I had
this flattle and y'all kids just learned
about it yeah
you know what it is though because
Arcane games require you to be willing
to mess around and if you don't that and
you play them very straight they can
come off like a boring shooter or like
pray if you play if you play Pray
straight like this is a boring shooter
and then you know if you're not willing
to be like hey I'm going to use this
black goo to like create a staircase up
to this thing and break through this if
you're not willing to do that it's going
to come off like a very boring game and
that's the thing about those games
dishonor the same thing if you're not
willing to engage with all the systems
they allow you to engage with you're not
going to get the most out of the game so
it could you can play it very straight
and be super bored by it and just be
like oh this is a this is an average
shooter at best or an average melee game
at best and not utilize everything
they're giving you I think that's been
the problem and that's why I understand
why they needed a death Loop and I
understand why heart a lot of Hardcore
people weren't super enthused by death
Loop right but it was to me it was
necessary for people to put put Arcane
on more people's Radars you know the
funny thing is like people talk all that
smack about death Loop and they
confirmed in like a stream a couple
months ago that death Loops in the disc
Dishonored Universe yes yes oh yes yeah
I can almost guarantee you you're
maybe not guaranteed but I'm highly
thinking that they're going to
eventually merge the two IPS together
yeah it's going to be like like Cole's
gonna come in like the Dishonored
Universe because they've been they've
been in a loop all this time like right
literally for years and years and years
they've been in this Loop so you know
the outsider clearly is the one doing it
ran finish your point I'm sorry well I
was gonna say you know you know how
incredibly exciting it must be for some
of those devs at Arcane yes where
they're like all right this is our
moment we're gonna release this game and
millions are gonna play it on Xbox and
Game Pass and PC this could be the
moment where we take the next step
because everybody is gonna be playing it
so we can showcase our skills and what
we actually like you you know as king
would stay you you know you speak with
your chest out right you say we're we
outside this is this is what we do this
is this is the part where you just come
out
the corner
[Laughter]
want that type of energy okay and I just
waiting for him to get old enough so I
can punch him
I call him McGregor beating up old
oh But continuing allegedly good to you
then well yeah I mean I I just that's I
mean that's really the point I wanted to
make was this like this could be the um
coming out party you know for for for
Arcane where people truly start to
recognize like how talented they are and
that they should be mentioned among some
of the best Studios working right now
and I'm I'm incredibly excited to see
you know because yeah I was I you know
originally when you watched that first
trailer you're like I don't know all
right
but the vampires it's like but then it's
like you're thinking about your head
wait a minute wait a minute it's Arcane
he's like wait a minute
they're built differently right they're
built different so then read this
interview and like everything in it was
just like okay yeah this oh oh this
sounds really good all right like this
this makes it this makes it way more
interesting to me and hopefully other
people
um yes
so with this new information and we know
how much of a fan you are of these games
where does the ranking call for
excitement versus starfit which has you
both oh redfall oh
I mean it's like it's like it's like
it's like red fall and then like the
next slide is Starfield yeah that's
where man
you know my number one most anticipated
game is Star Wars Jedi Survivor
I love I love that first game so like
they they get the number one spot number
two spot I think is Resident Evil before
because Resident Evil is one of my
favorite franchises and and two and four
were my like two favorite Resident Evils
so for them to remake it it's just like
I you know I'm there okay and then like
yeah it'd be like redfall Starfield you
know Spider-Man 2
um
but uh a dead spit Dead Space is there
as well there's face so okay okay
I never knew where you stood between
those two and this information is even
even more so clearly made me more
excited for redfall not that you're not
looking for something but as far as
you've got to break you're right but
remember I'm not the biggest fan of fall
I'm not the biggest falloff fan I love
Elder Scrolls got it but I am a sucker
for sci-fi
so a Sci-Fi but that's the game even
though I'm not really a fan of their
post-apocalyptic stuff gotcha I'm there
for their sci-fi thing you know all
right nah no doubt no doubt we got it
all wrapped up you want to get these
super chats and we just I think you know
I think I think this is probably where
I'll drop out oh brother yeah but do
your thing tell a fine people where they
can find you brother always good to have
you in the realm pulling up last minute
uh yeah happy to be on the Xbox two plus
I mean funny five funny how you are
always in the realm but I'm never
this is
what it is
but somehow some way I never getting it
right now I'm taking your knees right
now for it
you were literally on the Xbox 2 with me
and Paris oh yeah and Miles you got I
literally asked you and you were on what
are you talking about it was so long ago
so long ago
well I mean we don't do many we don't do
many guest shows oh we don't have one
just had one with cards like three okay
we're gonna go away
I'm talking about Guest shows
I'll do it cognito's been on there once
that's right
dude
I'm never canceling them they're always
on my TV I'm just under trying to
understand why I was there one I thought
wasn't I a good guess what an amazing
guys
but you also said you didn't want to do
it because we we did we run No cameras
and you're not allowed that way you know
what you're right what it is is you run
no camera damn straight I'm so good I
don't need to be on game okay this is
this is true I respect it but I'm
willing to play nice
you heard it here first but look Brad
where can the five people find I guess
salute to you salute you can't find us
[Laughter]
you know maybe I'll have to work on
getting King on for a second time thank
you I appreciate that stop the slander
thank you maybe we could do an Xbox two
plus one where it's just me and Jazz and
the Lords that's what's up
uh King uh go crazy on these PlayStation
topics would you oh it's gonna it's
about tequila I'm looking forward to it
much love bro always a pleasure later
guys
right quick
you never know when you need when you
need some Vaseline sorry dirt I don't
know
oh my God
what did he say I don't know moving on
you never know when you need some
Vaseline yeah
I get it but Dirt has a joke with that
Vaseline that is probably the funniest
thing I've ever heard it's griggity yes
yes his show he has this thing about the
Vaseline which is probably the funniest
thing I've ever heard all right
just just incredible guy two dollars
PS5 is better all right outside the
outside yeah as long as you ain't got it
standing up
I agree with that super chat
then we got Lord Metroid remember for
one year two dollars for chat Nintendo
Direct is good they they act they show
actual gameplay yeah okay well vertical
slices did you know that Graphics is
trash
happens yeah we got drive by Joe five
dollars
that's that dude
take his knees King
I got you brother there we got three bit
two dollars homie yeah star Builders
three three twenty three book it oh oh
we got that inside developer exclusive
three pesos okay I'll take that that's
that's in tax season
right then we got y'all baby five
dollars for chat a few months before 11
11 22 we were all wondering why we
wasn't seeing more from Starfield now we
still don't have a release date it's
looking shaky um
it's 20 23. stop it baby father
and we got done the taco five dollars
which have PC players will be too busy
pirating and playing Zelda to play
Starfield
I will say this I will be purchasing
that game day one and promptly ripping
it and playing it online
[Laughter]
but does the games have taken Game of
the Year from Zelda before
let it be
um
if Starfield Wins Game of the Year we'll
never hear that it will never hit it if
you come out in proximity of situations
let it be and you know what you know
what it's Starfield one game of the year
it would be the one I would be the most
excited of losing on anytime
yeah like I will I will I will jump on
that grenade
we got pragmatic Eagle member for 37
months thank you brother Lord gold wow
both sides are making sense while being
funny but let's be real as much as I
personally enjoyed Horizon zero Dawn
Horizon is not a Bethesda soft words can
be with King
right my guys are in the street
Starfield is not Elder Scrolls 6 either
pound gorillas tend to agree with me
yeah knocked out on the floor
sorry King can't agree with you on this
one Phil likes Nintendo won't really
start build against Zelda May
potentially uh May potentially has Brett
fall Zelda Suicide Squad Starfield
shouldn't come out in May May his
Suicide Squad
I'm just telling you don't duck the Fate
you're gonna have to fight one day Jimmy
[Laughter]
then we have con artistic five dollars
for chat King is Right Zelda can
Dominate and still not affect uh at uh
starfield's success thank you brother
for having clear thought
what could Starfield have more success
without Zelda there that's the question
you saw duck your face with me running
all your life
there we go uh Highlander one two dollar
Super Chat ghost water Tokyo is supposed
to come in March I mean that's
but it's one of those things like it for
a lot of people even if it's coming to
Game Pass it's an old Game Pass
Target to me those are the additive
games thank you argue to the member for
one year five dollars a check also
Nintendo has 120 million plus consoles
for Zelda Starfield is current gen only
so maybe 25 million plus BC uphill
battle hoping Starfield releases 3 23
23. I don't care winning release just
don't be afraid
stand up
y'all baby father ten dollars in the
chat I'm gonna start referring to all of
these I heard I'm hearing a little
birdie told me yes as NDA dudes
shut up
that's not like you straight got those
balls from king that's hilarious
hilarious I appreciate you know them
that we got yeah baby father get two
dollars of a chat they shook ain't no
such things as halfway Crooks
Prodigy man okay
I got across the street we gonna come
across the street anywhere
and we got AKA Havoc five dollars
yeah if you don't see the building okay
five dollars Super Chat where breath of
the Wall came out and outsold the switch
sales so put your chain you put your
Chase down
that is CR it outsold the system this is
crazy man you got people that was buying
hoping they can get a switch later
they're going to do points of sales well
direct sales you just cut them off at
the knees man then we got Ahmed Kumar
with the two dollar Super Chat yeah
that's the homie right there Fallout 4
sold 12 million on launch stay alone
let's be real who's the real King out
here Bethesda is a 800 pound gorilla for
real ping Kong in the building man
knocked out with that last fight though
they're coming off a knockout they're
coming off from knockout lost the chin
might not
have that [ __ ] might not be the same
sometimes okay sometimes you watching
and fighting you go oh oh the champ got
wobble
we just saying shout out to Israel
shout out to Roy Jones
that was a low flow that was a low blow
move it up I know what he doing let's go
get personal I want to move on
[Applause]
and we're gonna
face 23 bkny 20 big games in the first
half of 2023 Zelda Final Fantasy 16
Resident Evil 4 remake Hogwarts Legacy
let's go Street Fighter 6 Diablo Force
Garfield needs to avoid all these games
except the street by the sixth chairs
so you're cultivating you're cultivating
a suckers stop being afraid you just
name five games that you gonna run from
you're gonna run from every corner at
one point in time are you gonna fight
and beat it be that dude man stop
playing like that man
stop being a freak I gotta say though we
we eating this [ __ ] what a year what a
year this could be
remember but two years yeah what's up I
said I was talking to King like gaming
and movie-wise yeah
a lot of content is Going Bonkers
we got flame remember for two years
let's go no doubt happy New Year IOP
both Starfield and Zelda will have
massive player bases day one except one
will be 15 FPS and the other is Zelda Mr
yo
yo
wow
and still 15 frames per second
messy and we have X dimelo seven five
dollars we'll be chatting Starfield has
to come out when it's ready even if it
trespasses the dude
better to have a broken promise and a
broken game shout out to King yeah
I can't flow with that you like broken
promises right all right
swing on them
then we got Leroy is the master five
dollar Super Chat Talk That Talk get
that Kool-Aid mess out of here
that's what I'm talking about real dude
stand up messy Lords let's go today yeah
we have space Dover King two dollar
Super Chat hashtag xno no doubt all
right
then we got done a taco five dollar
Super Chat my brothers can we stop the
fighting Xbox and nintendrons stand
together as the only ones with games of
2023 let us dominate Sony together we'll
do that he's an alliance so they got
that thing going up to this year people
sleeping
and we have abacab 72 member for one
year five dollars for chat didn't Xbox
just do a direct for World War long
that's what they need for Starfield and
redfall maybe Forza did they have an
event for wolves
the demo okay yeah then we have Luffy
the goat or Luffy is I guess is Luffy
Luffy the goat two pound Super Chat I've
been off the grid what happened the
whole law yes a whole had a had a
medical situation over the holiday uh he
was in the hospital
um he's still in the hospital
um he's slowly recovering yes yes wish
all the best yeah follow at Mrs Hogue
law on Twitter or if you loaded the
whole glow YouTube channel go to his
community page they post updates on his
condition so you can see what's going on
with my brother he's on the man who wish
him all the best
then we have easy five dollar Super Chat
really looking forward to Starfield and
redfall but the real question is where
is silk song at talk about it it's gotta
be in the first six months uh much love
to the iron Lords and Rand yeah Hollow
Knight
Luffy the goat I'm sorry if I'm saying
it wrong Luffy Luffy they let me know
two pound Super Chat man man like King
with his gangster silver beard
yeah yeah then we got drive by Joe
yesterday's knees are not today's news
yo
yo
he said I don't got expired news
hold on a second I gotta roll back a
little bit we got a couple okay hold on
a second
yeah we have yesterday's knees no right
let me go back so we have everybody we
got Tyson Lewis ten dollars a good chat
what's up family wishing y'all the best
2023 and Beyond and hellblade 2 for me
and hopefully Flintlock may be a
surprise yes Flintlock look good for
crazy yeah
we have Jesh two dollar stupid chat glad
to see IOP back in 2023 much love
likewise and appreciate the Super Chat
the like button
we have splendiferous two dollar Super
Chat bow down non-believers Mr Todd got
balls of steel
balls with a z
cracking balls and Dragon Balls we got
Lord Metro two dollars Super Chat Zelda
is an institution Starfield has to prove
not has to prove Nava has to prove
itself I guess okay there's a lot of
Institutions that have some white
classes too
I can get knocked out there's whack
classes in Harvard yeah I guess yes it
is there's some classes that you choose
not to tell you better spend your money
wisely Champs get knocked out every day
B here we go then we got a difference
again two dollars Super Chat y'all need
a PS5 to play the psvr so stop it now
see that that's kind of rough then we
got GSD get AKA getting stuff done five
dollar Super Chat happy New Year gents
anyone get the valari uh Roy pillows yet
wow oh we don't if you choose if you
choose to sit on it that's all you do
that's on you whatever your condition is
and that helps you the main help that
wet couch you got
nothing a little Preparation H won't fix
up bro
for those trying to get their gaming on
you know what I'm saying exactly links
in the description
I know I know that price tag is a little
cost prohibitive
[Music]
I turned 41 tomorrow my birthday wishes
for Xbox to knock it out the park in
2023 shout out to the room happy early
birthday time
happy birthday are we all caught up yes
we are caught up Sir should probably do
a combination flow with these two and
then oh real quick getting stuff done I
bought mine I'm just asking I bought
mine I'm just asking and I used the
cream on the side whoa whoa
look we got to get to it man so uh yeah
I want to probably combine these um
there's a lot of Sony information
um Sony huge CES a lot of announcement
PS5 over 30 million sold worldwide Jim
Ryan president of Sony interactive
revealed the figure and he said it's uh
up 5 million from the 25 million figure
revealed two months and November 1st I
truly appreciate the support and Pace uh
patience of the PlayStation Community as
they manage unprecedented demand amid
Global challenges over the past two
years so they're kind of uh saying that
you know you gotta expect like the
shortage over as far as uh consoles and
availability so they said on the happy
said that December was the biggest month
ever for PS5 console sales and we now
again sold the 30 million confident
supply issues are not now solve
completely Ryan stated that everyone who
wants a PS5 should have a much easier
time finding one at retail globally
starting from this point forward then it
also had the psvr too a lot of
announcements obviously the February
22nd date
um said that I've launched with over 30
titles including Horizon calling the
mountain no man's Sky Gran Turismo has
uh why does this man have a Game Pass
background flicker in the back
um Regular People Village and um also
shout out they landed beat saber in
development huge there we go huge title
for VR a lot of questions if beat saber
would come to the platform they said
they don't have the date to announce
that time and I know who's coming soon
and oh shout out to him buck is here
um so what I was going to do today
you're gonna have to call me mega bucks
oh [ __ ] so um look you know that we've
got
um obviously part of these titles for me
personally I want a shout out I don't
have dbm and Zenith the last series part
of that
um lineup also project Leonardo
accessibility controller announced for
players with disability go check that
out while logical we want them all yeah
huge thing we know obviously that um the
access accessibility space is kind of
like yeah first we saw what Microsoft
was doing we said you know what I have a
cousin named Leonardo yo don't do that
don't do that so we named it after my
cousin
we have uh three more Ninja Turtles that
we're gonna use okay we got Michelangelo
working on the foot pedals but um
um yeah so look again we got the sales
numbers we got the the shortage issue
um also kind of alluded because a lot of
people like you know
okay what do you talk about I mean Cog
what do you talk about as far as the
light up and um so pretty much they
obviously said Spider-Man 2 you know
they're promoting that as far as 2023
lineup for spoken Final Fantasy 16 which
we do know is coming to the platform at
least exclusive for some time Final
Fantasy 7 remake part two potentially
more information on Last of Us to spoken
factions right and um interesting so I
don't know if you caught Hogwarts Legacy
if they're marketing almost like they're
exclusive in a sense right so yeah I
thought that was interesting that's a
dungeon yeah it lasts but at least for
for buck or king or whomever which I
thought was quite interesting
they had the uh Saudi whip y'all I don't
know if y'all saw it the concept called
a Sony whip y'all yeah
they got this it's called the uh the
Honda the Sony Honda afila you know
that's right tell the true Shane the
devil feels good feel it yeah Joy
Venture with Sony and Honda set the loss
in North America Casa card spring in
2026 and uh yeah you got a PS4
that's
possible
well what what I've noticed is you know
a lot of times
um we weren't gonna sell
obviously that's a lie the lie detector
proved that was a lie 30 million dollars
not [ __ ] baby 30 million sold through so
this means that oh
all and I mean all the scalpers have got
the PlayStation 5.
they have sold through to every scalper
that we need
Ed and all this
all a shout out to um Leonardo for
getting that done oh yeah
I had him on the supply chain so we had
to name a controller after him my man
has come through in Spades
what's going on right now right now the
checks have cleared uh the PlayStation
VR is is launching with uh 29 unoriginal
games
yeah yeah but we got Horizon though
that's that one game you ain't see no
place else baby
the launcher with one killer app baby
one killer app
you need a PlayStation 5 though
because we're not back compact but um
understand understand
that's right tell them tell them little
me little me little me likes to purchase
again so we're gonna remaster we're
gonna remix
tell us tell us what you talk about
little me little me is out here though
that's the PlayStation fan voices
we will continue to dominate along with
the rest of the year shout out to
PlayStation PlayStation put your hands
in right here
what I wanted to ask not at least I've
had box appearance on these
announcements or you know in reference
to you know the 30 mil and and how you
know they they really saw us a king of
series X Atticus series
I don't know what's going on YouTube but
oh yeah like about the all these
announcers what's your thoughts on it
let's start with addict now that he's
got his voice back
I don't care about the million continue
I don't care about them they they can
sell 50 60 70. just keep giving me games
kind of like God of War and we good all
right so how you feel about that then
line up
um
Spider-Man 2 for spoken Final Fantasy 16
final free settings Final Fantasy 7
remake part two potentially at the end
of the year we made part twos I'm
excited for 16 I'm a little iffy on
um I'm seeing a little bit of stuff
that's making me really excited for it
uh for spokens in the bushes under the
bushes and
I I don't know like part of me
they they're doubling down on on
Spider-Man 2 so I'm hoping it comes up
this year but we ain't see no gameplay
on that uh I I wasn't I thought 2018
Spider-Man was okay I didn't think it
was like amazing uh but I do think that
I really enjoyed I do think I really
enjoyed miles gameplay more than
theaters in 2018 so you know the fact
that you could place both Venom's in it
too so yeah you know I think it's going
to be a solid experience as long as
nothing gets pushed back because you
know we are in a state that everything
likes getting delayed I think it's gonna
be a solid solid year for PlayStation no
doubt Lord solve what are we thinking
cell through them 30 Milli outside ship
through and availability yeah what you
think about it that's the mo that's the
mo like they got to tell consoles you
know and they you know finally you know
the the stock is catching up to demand
uh and you know Xbox has had a long time
to sort of fill in that those demands
for people who can't find PlayStation
Asian and you know what we're going to
Xbox and then coming to Xbox and being
excited about what they see on Xbox so
um yeah 30 million this is the ammo
right this is the ammo they're not gonna
ever really get there you know with
their with their sort of game pass-esque
offering
um they're not really gonna get there
they're not doing a day and date
whatever so it's console sales and until
but I still feel the same way right I
think Xbox is changing the changing the
The Rules of Engagement with Game Pass
and what they do on the console side and
the PC side but I do still feel like you
got to kind of beat them at their own
game at some point right uh to really
kill this whole idea that the way they
do things is the way it's supposed to be
right and and and the subscription model
stuff is the future So and I've you know
you know I think pactor said something
to the effect like hey this year you
know in terms of like Hardware Xbox
might be you know it might be there with
them right especially if you said that
if you have to finish yeah so they you
know it's interesting and again they
need to sell those consoles because
that's that is their whole ammo in the
game um when it comes to the stuff that
I saw on psvr too I'm there day one psvr
two
um but the only thing that really just I
want to see I want to see if it stands
up to Half-Life Alex levels of sort of
hype is Call of the mountain right I
want to see because when you look at the
specs of that place uh psvr 2 in
conjunction with obviously the power of
the machine
this is the lowest price high end
headset you're going to be able to find
right anything else you know we just saw
the vibe to whatever is going to be it's
a 1200 or whatever the case may be you
know we've seen the The Meta Quest Pro
these things that are untethered and
unattached but are still you know twice
the price of what the PlayStation is
well obviously it's the same because you
have to you have a PlayStation 5 but you
know what I mean
um so I to me when they tell me oh beat
Sabers coming beat Sabers on every
platform known to me like I'm just
when they tell me b-tapers coming it's
not necessarily coming at launch I'm
like what have y'all been doing okay
okay it's weird like it's like beat
saber should be go without saying um the
fact that they said a Gran Turismo uh
sort of upgrade is going to be offered
to people that own the game and it
should be there at launch it's cool but
for me it's I ordered the I ordered the
bundle we'll call it the mountain yeah
that's going to be my primary thing that
day one I want to see what that offers
that sort of compares to Half-Life Alex
and you know where the hell is half-life
Alex look I'm just come on okay let's
talk to Gabe we got to get this done
like Half-Life Alex
it's still obviously you can play it on
meta Quest you can right if you attach
it to your PC and you can do that
um but it needs to be native on another
platform and and to allow more people to
play that game because I think games
like you know Half-Life Alex uh
boneworks bone Labs that type of stuff
those are the games that really are the
high water points of VR and I just think
it needs to be in more places so again
uh for me let's put the dirty though at
the launch 30 Games the old games
otherwise yeah it's just I it's a lot I
just don't think they have the ones that
really like for me like our you know
Village right Village I would have to
purchase Village again
wholesale right to play it on the
PlayStation because I have it on Xbox I
actually have it on PC as well right so
it's just one of those things I'm not
purchasing Village for uh
so it's just things like that where
specific instances because of what my
library entails right isn't super
exciting for me got you okay
um and I'm not gonna re-buy this stuff
on on the PlayStation platform I'm I'm
there PlayStation for me in every aspect
is for PlayStation games got it okay
and it's just one it's yeah it's kind of
just one hacking game I haven't played
moss and I haven't purchased Moss
anywhere so I might get I might get book
one and two on the psvr too because I
happen to do that right yeah or or you
might go get a cheaper option
it is cheaper elsewhere especially yeah
and you do have other options though
yeah but I'm again again the 30 billion
they're going to keep talking console
sales until console sales don't matter
and I don't know anytime soon
rather than later I think you know you
still got to beat them at their own game
I think that's right can't duck that
fate yeah to King you know uh 30 million
Soul King very successful you know
thriving out here I mean you have been
one to say that they might not be a
PlayStation 6 with these numbers they're
doing it I mean at some point in time
when you look over you'll be like 30
million I see you know what I love
though I love the cat
I love the cat I love the cap I love
dudes that's in the chat 30 million we
outside you brought one shut up
shut up you are part of nothing you are
part of a Dying Bree that's like saying
we're you the last dinosaurs 30 million
of y'all
she right in the back of the head y'all
gonna go right to sleep and we're gonna
be talking about fossil fuel later on
it's over B like this is your last great
stand 30 million oh so what 30 million
in five good games 30 million and one of
them is DLC so let's talk about this
wonderful year that you gonna have y'all
gotta y'all not confident on Spiderman
I hear all y'all talking you're not
confident on Spider-Man I heard for
smoking is for broken
so you gotta be for joking
on that one game all right so for
smoking is too woke it's too old for a
lot of you dudes so y'all can't get that
can I understand what code word for woke
me nowadays
all right so PlayStation VR
stop the cat no it's a cat stop the job
stop the cat you dudes can't even buy a
PlayStation 5 you talk about a VR and
you need a place I had a VR stop the cat
you guys ain't getting it
you all right you're gonna get it let's
say you do have a PlayStation 5. you
would just throw a bass already yeah
yeah 30 30 million y'all not buying it
right because it was a 125 million
PlayStation 4s and only 5 million VR so
this is a passion project for somebody
all right wow so so let's look at it
right if we're going to use the same
metrics from before because y'all love
using these numbers these numbers sound
good so it's 30 million y'all had a
hundred and twenty something million you
only got five million out of them dudes
to get down with what you got and they
had a better lineup than what's showing
up right now right so basically so you
got 30 million of you guys right now so
I only look at a hundred thousand of you
guys gonna buy so 100 000 of you guys
going by let's get your way on a rival
yeah finish so you only got one title
that is exclusive to your car to your
console one title that is DLC from
something else that's a failed project
all right so you've got one film project
that you're trying to launch with
another fail project to a failed project
it's a DOA on the right they somebody
in that building want to make sure that
we never hear VR again oh my God right
no because okay listen
I have a I have a meta Quest two
all those games in your list B I can go
get those right now cheaper and I don't
got to be Tethered to nothing
so don't tell me about the Fidelity of
each eye each eye has an Oculus and I
have a heptic feedback in my headset and
what what I'm feeling you're feeling
like a DLC with one game and all those
games is cheaper someplace else all you
guys got TCL televisions I know how
cheap you are you're not buying all
right so it's a hundred thousand of you
dudes that's going to buckle down ten
toes down in the ground that is DOA
that's a waste of a conversation so
let's get to the main event before you
before you get to the main event so so
you feel what about like when you hear
about the Gran Turismo and they're going
to have a VR
what did you see inside what I saw it it
looked like the hot dog water
I saw it it looked like hot dog water
and they talk about it might not be
ready for a launch what are you talking
about it for you had a you had a real
car
playing PlayStation stuff and that's
your main event let's get to the games
man let's get to what's really shaking
out in these streets Final Fantasy yeah
uh uh uh coming out that's that's a good
game exclusive no Spiderman whoa you
don't know this is what we say I'm
looking for it no but I want it okay for
sure for sure that's gonna probably be
my game of the year no matter what the
hell came out I don't care what come out
Spider-Man is gonna be my game of the
year I don't care what comes out man
that comes out I love me some Spider-Man
no doubt you know Spiderman he's sitting
right here
that's the Spider-Man suit from the
PlayStation 4 version hello here you're
right here right here y'all guys can't
say it's right here ain't nowhere in
your house
um but I support in that manner so
that's the game that I'm looking for at
the end of the year that's the big
ticket item that's the only item this
year to be honest with you because like
Sovereign set I only played him for
exclusive so if you got one exclusive
that I'm looking for forward that 30
million means nothing oh if nobody's
playing there
okay and I don't believe you anyway
because I got a lot I got a lot of
scalpers to have these things prices
ain't dropping the scalping world so
that means a profit and supply and
demanding real because it's not in the
stores
so what who you sold it through to be oh
now we don't believe enough now we don't
believe enough
no I believe somebody brought them but I
don't believe it was people
every software has a PlayStation
if it's sold through what's your
engagement numbers to show up the real
numbers who actually play single player
games
but I mean somebody got to turn them on
right
we do with our third eye open conspiracy
yeah how many how many are because
remember the news came out before they
said these numbers before Oh we had 20
million but we found out only four
million of them was turned on oh but so
we want to know how many is turned on
who's playing these things because I
still got pictures of dudes in
warehouses with all the Playstations and
I don't see you guys with any
PlayStation so just so record with Xbox
they say it's 20 billion theirs is
legitimate though no there's no scalpers
involved
this is where this is where yo 30
million is that it's at this Warehouse
with the Grinch don't tell and none of
them is turned on none of y'all got a
PlayStation none of you dudes just
buying a place Station 2 VR is only a
hundred thousand is gonna get it that
thing is Dead on Arrival God bless is
that all right with 30 billion and okay
so so you think 30 million gonna buy how
many how many you think gonna buy okay
no I'm just saying because it just
seemed to fly in the face of your
argument that the ps6 is dead so I feel
you going strong oh the PlayStation 6 is
not showing up I think you're going
strong but you know what you know I'll
be throwing you a bone to that would be
nice give me that I was gonna be very
Petty with you today and I was gonna be
like this flies right in the face of
your theory but I'm gonna throw you
King King right now is very very
aggressive today so um what I saw shout
out to games industry that Biz
um had an article as far as predictions
are concerned and as far as um you know
kind of like what potential things could
happen in the industry as far as closing
the Gap and um obviously we know about
you know 30 but then but you left
some analysts of trying to get uh have
made a statement say they expect
um Kevin Carroll Cervin from
gamesindustry.biz and this uh media and
Tech Allen just says that Xbox had
narrow PlayStations lead in 2023 they
said that um they believe Xbox will
significantly narrow the Gap due to
Microsoft's Hardware agnostic efforts
and to focus and the focus to provide
value for money and any pretty much goes
on to say
the adverse micro economic climate
couples with Xboxes cross-platform and
Hardware agnostic efforts as well as its
focus to provide value for money and
mitigate the requirement for consumers
to part with large sums of money at once
and then he just goes on to talk about
how obviously inflation the effects of
inflation uh disposable income
tightening disposable income will be in
full spring in 2023 consumers will be
looking to do two key things decrease
overall spending and increase value for
money with their purchases and
traditionally gaming has had a high
entry point cost obviously the 70 Games
and Things that nature so he feels
basically the summary is Xbox is in
position the way they're constructed
um to kind of suit this need and he
feels that they will significantly close
this Gap what do you feel about these
thoughts sir
um
I believe that he's on something
also also also
what's the number they at now with no
games
allegedly 20 minutes allegedly what
allegedly 20 million 20 million so
there's a 10 million gap no games so
this is the year game show up and this
get this year looking sparse for you
so not tremendously a lot of the uh
investors and a lot of the analysts
gonna say this is going to be a hell of
a year for Xbox
so they looking at it as a hell of a
year what happens if they sell is trying
to catch up and pass you do what happens
what happens now I don't expect y'all to
stay stagnant but I don't think the
PlayStation 2 VR is going to sell any
any extra additional consoles I don't
think there's a person sitting outside
saying that PlayStation VR coming I've
been waiting to get my PlayStation 5 now
so let me go drop 1400.
that's just one game though Spiderman b
game
it's a big game but what I'm saying is
you got to take into account we don't
know what's happening to this Activision
thing if if they snatch Call of Duty for
Game Pass next year because that gets
closed that trumps anything Spider-Man
can do it's just being realistic like
literally Call of Duty outsells
everything in two months then the entire
year does combine them oh factual
factual I mean again assuming big
assuming that the deal goes through but
to your point you're correct I don't
think car goes to Game Pass anyway way
though right isn't there a deal in place
of race like 2027 for that not to happen
yeah the rumor suggests that we'll pay
you to find
it
we'll move on again how I see it is Xbox
closes the gap
by at least 2026 the writing is going to
be all over the walls the PlayStation
gonna be an app over
I already told you it ain't gonna be a
PlayStation 6. I'm standing firming in
my firm that my convictions
yo 30 million is a is a very small right
remember we already know what the
ceiling is 25. we just curiosity when we
were talking about um Spider-Man didn't
they announce that's a PlayStation 5
only guy yeah
are you gonna are you gonna bend the
knee now or later no see what I'm gonna
do is after after they get their sales
and everybody get in and they announced
that the PlayStation 4 would not be left
behind I'm just gonna double back on you
and just pick these up so I'ma spin the
block that's fine you can double back
all you want are you gonna bend the knee
now
see what it is is you that dude that
don't got hope right so what you feel is
what you feel I had enough hope to make
that bet to take them knees again and
you almost you almost lost
fear see fear keeps you from taking that
leap I don't have no fear because when I
knock you out
and then when I do and it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
I'm gonna land that punch you're gonna
be hitting punches all night I'm gonna
lie in that punch and when you go and
your body go twisting and you go looking
wild and it's looking crazy the only
thing the crowd is gonna remember is
that dude said he was going to do that
that's the only thing they remember that
dude said he was gonna do it and it
happened it's gonna be spectacular when
it does our man is too tough man
are you gonna bend the need now or are
you going to be the need later
five are you gonna Bend to me I don't
like that voice see the thing is what
you don't know about the one-hitter
quitter you don't see because you've
been running for Fades a lot you don't
know I know
it's a face
I stood there fought the best of them
sometimes you win something
listen son sometimes you win some
sometimes you lose but you but you live
to fight another day
and your name is in these streets your
name ring bells
in these shirts because I already got
the knees
what's the best thing I like about you
is you're fearful
you make bets when you think you got a
98 chance of winning
him that acceptance
listen I'm that dude that take that two
percent I'm running there with that two
percent if I land that shot on your chin
buddy and you start to wiggle and start
this shake that's all I need to see
that's fine it's 98 took that means
confidence I like you leaning leaning
because we're gonna clip this out like
George Burns he's talking about that guy
like what's going on
health issues with that voice yeah
we saw this deathbed yo when Jim walked
back and say and for the PlayStation
crowd the PlayStation crowd four we have
Spider-Man 2 as well
I want to see the blood drain out your
body
anyway move it all past you let's go
ridiculous um
like that oh it's not like Beaufort yeah
somebody said he sound like he need Life
Alert oh move it off so yeah those are
pretty much enough so check that out it
was a good thing and then I guess we'll
combine this last one which is King's
topic so we're saying PlayStation
Centric today uh yeah some some news
came out that kick brought to our
attention
see that kick is always the depth at
fighting uh news like this oh yes off
the vert I guess we're gonna call this
off the vert um yeah shout out to WCC
tank uh PlayStation 5 design floor might
kill the castle by using it vertically
so it looks like
um this uh repair shop owners are
talking about whether or not as far as
uh vertically placement that it can do
permanent damage to the console due to a
critical design flaw the problem is that
the liquid metal used to cool the Apu
can sometimes spell and become uneven
which impacts the Kings I'm laughing Ben
Montana the owner of the specialized
repair shop I love my console in French
shout out to Ben Montana
um he's just been trying to bring
attention to the issue for months he
said these are not isolated cases
according to him the risk is high for
ps5s that have been standing vertically
for a long time and he says all models
are impacted this includes the digital
and standard versions of the console
several cases of this problem has shown
that the PS5 seal between the Apu and
its cooler can sometimes move when
damaged and when that is the case if
your PS5 sits horizontally the liquid
metal will stay flat and keep most of
its thermal properties to help cool the
PS5 but suppose your PS5 is vertical and
something bad happens to the seal in
that case there is risk that the liquid
metal will progressively fall down
becoming uneven impacting its cooling
ability and possibly reaching components
it shouldn't so this is going around the
interwebs King this is your topic you
would clearly want to discuss this yes
yes lay that big dude on its stomach
he did not do leg day he do not got the
calf muscles
to appreciate himself so please lay that
big dude
you don't like to work out
good deal we all knew he looked weird
and we you know remember the PlayStation
dudes is like oh man it has the liquid
metal inside
from the fastest thing to the liquid
metal to the rippable wings terrific yo
this has been a unmitigated disaster
you want to help yo why give it an
option you know Sony knew that you can't
stand it up do not stand up do not stand
it up addict lay it on his belly
that's the wrong side you got to turn it
on his belly
right now it must be flat if you hold
like oh no no attic please
it might get too hot and start to melt
on the inside and to think they remove
heat sinks you'll just think they made
the risk higher please let alone lay it
on the side do not do not it has high
cholesterol oil
I don't like that
has high cholesterol so what you're
saying
what you're saying is just gotta be like
that it gotta lay flat you cannot lay
that you cannot have him standing up he
cannot stand for too long you ever see a
dude standing up for too long he's
starting to sweat
PlayStation 5 kept you on his feet
all day
[Laughter]
that thing must lay on his stomach at
all times yeah
he said he got the meat to it so okay
it's not built for leg day man
no attic please
we don't want to snuff film
the design is a terrible design oh boy
can't even stand up we heard about how
loud it get but we heard now that it
can't stand up
we heard that it gets hot yo
let's let's tell the truth
the PlayStation 5 needed diet is
suffering from a lot of things going on
high cholesterol
overheating better questions if they
tell you if you go to the doctor right
and the doctor tell you you need to stay
off your feet okay you know things might
happen to you and the doctor tell you
you're overheating so you need to drink
you need to be in a cool space
this console
it's a big problem and and it's loud too
so you gotta
it's a terrible design I'm just glad
that somebody found it and Sony's not
owning up to it so shout out to the shop
owner
so he's Fearless right he's this is what
we're doing we had to talk about it talk
about it be about it man
that's what his um addict to your
thoughts on the PS5 potential vertical
design flaw
well you know I I got to keep it on its
stomach for now
I can't I can't risk yourself
me I I will be keeping it off its legs
from now on it can't I can't I can't let
it fall over and break
and that's that's all I really got to
say I'm fan of fish but as an Xbox
PlayStation Fanboy
what I have to say
is with this PlayStation is fine no
matter what it does king I don't know
what you're talking about it's fine on
its stomach it's fine on his feet it's
fine on its back it's okay no matter
where it goes King I don't know where
you get the audacity to come at the
PlayStation like it is
[Music]
yeah
I should know what I get into with these
topics
um
your thoughts are the potential PS5
designs so uh uh my PS5 has been
verticals since the very beginning I
told y'all about the herniated exit
PlayStations about them disc version
PlayStations that disk drive does not
belong there if this if there's truth to
this they said both versions
not as much because the the movement
caused by the disk drive could be if
this is the case could be causing this
to jostle that whatever that liquid
metal loose right uh so if that is the
case it could be another reason why
we're you know it's been rumored they
haven't announced it yet but it could be
another reason why they are essentially
eliminating the old version the old
version with the disk drive right
exactly so the baseboard version will be
just a a digital PS5 and they'll give
you the option to purchase a disk drive
separately which I don't know if it'll
it'll just be a wire connecting or you
can physically attach it to make it look
like a like a like an OG PS5 I don't
know why you would do that because a lot
of people thought that was ugly anyway
so I I think it'd just be a Side Drive
um one question mitigating that problem
yeah I just want to ask you a question
and just because you brought this up do
you think the digital version was a
thought processor behind everything from
the beginning and they were just too
scared to take that plunge and now with
all the stuff that's going around
because they know what goes on with the
console I mean I think the digital
version yeah yeah I mean to me the
digital this the thing what they did
with the digital version was this right
there weren't too many at launch right
they wanted to just give the appearance
of a lesser price point than the Xbox
right they did that right but there were
very few of them out in the market I was
surprised that I was able to fire one
um and then now when they look at the
majority of their sales being digital
now they can step all the way into that
yeah because but to me in the beginning
it was them taking the baby step like
okay let's see yeah and then when they
see like the vast majority of their
sales are digital now so now it does it
doesn't make sense now the question is
how Much Is That Base PS5 going to be
without the disk drive I I tell you this
I don't think it's 400.99 it's going to
be 500 plus this drive or at least or
450. I don't think they're giving you
that base PS5 for 3.99 anymore oh no
because they don't have to they don't
have to they don't have to uh and then
like I said there's very few of those
out in Wild as opposed to the disc
version so if there's a if there's truth
to this and and you know in in big
numbers it could be that they were
quietly fixing it with this I was going
to say because didn't
um talk to Jimmy champagne in them
didn't Line This tactics recently
discovered that there's a new model PS5
like right that they wish they changed
some of the energy yeah right right and
there was always a thing where they
changed up the heatsink where the
heatsink was huge before and now it
wasn't as much so I mean they've always
you know both console manufacturers are
going to are going to figure out ways to
make the production of the machine
cheaper right
um on the PlayStation side again we this
is something that just came out of of uh
a repair person who has seen a lot of
this yeah and I guess and all of that
sort of snowballed into this time we do
need to get failure rates yeah and all
of that but if the if there is truth to
it and Playstation is cognizant of this
then you know this disk drive thing
could be a way to quietly mitigate it
without it being a thing I'm sure if it
was partially that reason then they're
like man damn it it's out there right
somebody somebody's talked about it but
again failure rates we have to see what
it really is I don't I'm gonna be honest
with you I have a big uh like a big sort
of entertainment center type thing it's
not not at all but it but it's pause
it's a it's fairly it's fairly long
um I had to take out on on the ends of
it I have uh I had a uh what you would
call a shelf that made it into fours
right into two and two two and two I
took out the middle Shelf so you can
accommodate the space and I could
accommodate for the PS5 no and the Xbox
too because the Xbox I was like you know
I'm gonna put the Xbox vertically to and
I have them both vertically okay I don't
but again that's a big cabinet I can't
lay down that PlayStation that cabinet
it would literally it would be diagonal
in the cabinet like this I can't lay it
down so it's like
it's it's crazy yo it's one of those
things like it's not even really built
to be laid down unless you have it just
out in the open somewhere on top or
something can you take your wings off
because if we found out that the wings
aren't necessary you can take the Wings
off and replace them if you want no I'm
talking about to lay it down in your
your entertainment centers you just lay
it butt naked yo
put it
so so I tried to ground it thank you for
your service I appreciate it this is
what might help with the liquid for the
PlayStation you just take the Wings off
and let it be button into the top of it
this guy this guy oh you must stop
seeing a lot of [ __ ] PlayStation 5. but
I will say this though like that that
machine if you think about it space wipe
is not really made to be laid down
there's no cabinet that really yeah
because if the cabinet if the cabinet
could accommodate the machine vertically
guarantee that horizontally it has like
this much space to Breathe Right yo my
my joint is my joint is laying down
right now right and it's always been
laying down I never thought to stay in
that big space heater up
but he he laying down in the room now I
might strip them naked
[Music]
[Music]
I did have to rip out a thing uh a
partition yeah because it's so big like
you can't yeah because it's a very thick
laws well situation so um just take the
Wings off let it be nice I did take the
waves off to put in the um the SS what
is it the uh the extra oh you added
that's just see I haven't done it yeah
yeah I want for extra space so um did
they send your engineering degree
every time you buy SSD for them you get
an engineering it's Justice Phillips a
screwdriver sir that's all it took for
that but uh yeah we'll see I mean the
failure rates it will be interested if
we start to hear more of this as a
console it's seriously if the castle
generation continues to go on and you
start to hear more of it but right now I
gotta I Gotta See Fair Race I gotta hear
more it will be interesting if it does
it does exist and it became widespread
and it's only quietly
we're making revisions and this is
something that they are aware of yeah
not addressing the actual issue but
making new ones and say just go buy
another one which is right anyway so
yeah that's what I got on this topic
that's all I got you want to get the
stupid chest or you'll be doing yeah
almost like yeah I just got this last
Super Chat from player yeah I got
everything I forget
oh they got you [ __ ]
continue
rumors of the Xbox game showcase a
minute how do you what do you feel
should be Xbox's primary focus on the
show's Direction the choices are a
updated gameplay trailers of red four
star field Forza and any new IP
B roadmap for 2023 with release dates
window
C separate Starfield for its own show
and deep dive that as the Crown Jewel or
D I don't care but I better not hear
about waiting until anything in 2024 for
these games so shout out to everybody
the poll will be up after the show is
concluded up on the Iron Horse podcast
Twitter so go check that out but uh so
I'll just get these uh super checks baby
yes sir okay we have Tom from Toonami
remember for six months five dollars
Sony revealing that a Fila is as in a
Fila getting away from making the ps6
we shall see we shall see we got Stitch
remember for 37 months Lord gold snitch
book book how do you feel about Ryan
snitching and how good Sony doing after
increasing prices
um saying there's a contract no that the
snitching is crazy you know we what we
about out here
all right and increasing prices I
already told you he's gonna do you how
he chooses because he knows you're gonna
take it so keep on taking it 30 million
y'all keep taking it I'm part of the 30
million I'm with you
then we got Luffy to go two pounds of
attack it's Luffy as in Luffy uh ROM
from One Piece my G no doubt oh now
forget that no I figured but I just want
to be sure oh that 100 sure that Luffy
was spelled like that India okay
by the way by the way there is a game uh
about grammar and that's right now that
I think many people would benefit from
this guy this guy
he got argue to the remember for one
year ten dollars of attack just pointing
out another failure for the FTC meta
releasing beats saber on a competing VR
platform takes another bite out of their
pointless claims within within with the
within acquisition by meta yes once
again
ah you know no camera moving on no
camera
they're not at risk of nothing exactly
splendiferous two dollar Super Chat
robots don't play games Jimmy people do
[Laughter]
we got Karn artistic two dollars of a
chat 30 mil consoles versus Game Pass
subscribed we will see who wins out and
we got blade x five dollar Super Chat
across the spider-verse and Spider-Man 2
come out this year it's about to sell
like crazy yeah that's I mean
Spiderman's gonna sell no questions did
it sell 120 something million sit down
it's gonna do what it always does yeah a
strong seven Jimmy Strong seven until we
had our kitchen team member for year
five dollar Super Chat PS5 telling King
I'm not fat I'm big boned it's not bad
shimmy wow all we gotta do is just rip
off the wings
ready yeah
this voice thing addict doing is amazing
I love it
you have a heartbeat you should need two
dollars of a chat so wait naked PS5
won't release its fluids wow wow
yeah you don't want to get the flu it's
too hot
wow so just wrap a towel around his SSD
and laid on his stomach
so
let me take over this oh yeah it's fun
we got Flames to two dollars Super Chat
this is the greatest Xbox podcast
returned this year we got not an Xbox
podcast we had a two dollar secret shot
from Dawn and talking oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
happy holidays and happy New Year IOP
fam that mid-gen refresher PlayStation
better not count as the ps6
yeah we got Dorian Gray two dollars but
Chad just don't call the PS5 obese no no
no no no no no it's not obese he just
needs a little bit of uh weight loss we
gotta put PlayStation on a diet
there's not a lot of games coming
all right so we made it we made it yes
salute back to the year here we are in
the building the realm returned much
loved everybody that pulled up Lord
addict where can I find people find you
with your multiple voices and all the
crazy things that you'd be doing what's
going on those other people are
different people that's I don't know
what you're talking about
another you're making me sound crazy I'm
not going to institution yet
we could find me on uh Twitter Lord
addict IOP I'll probably be streaming
um
punch out
tomorrow yeah tomorrow I don't know when
tomorrow probably like five six eight
six p.m ish just be look out for the um
I'll post the live stream thing where it
says uh I'm I'm live streaming I gotta
figure out exactly where to play that I
think it's on
definitely uh
hit me up there I'll be posting some
more videos on my YouTube channel uh we
got a couple things I'm working on a
couple things for you guys uh you know I
don't I it should be ready next week I
don't know Donald Taco said it's on
Nintendo switch online it's a punch out
get this online okay
should be ready next week hopefully uh
you know we are going to restructure
like all the member stuff all the
patreon stuff drastically uh me King
have some stuff we're going to do on r r
there we're gonna do some stuff with all
the shows uh we really want to bring the
value to that uh and I hope you guys uh
enjoy that
at extreme high in life
why does people want me to stream that
game that bad everywhere I turn stream
high in life at it every extreme high in
life addict I mean we can put a what's
recorder in the beginning of it yeah
like a disclaimer let's let's let me get
through he's like let me deal with punch
out first yeah all right let me get
through a punch out and then I will look
into stranger so you've never played
Punch Out Mike Tyson's punch out never I
think I played it on the Wii U but it
wasn't a lot no it might be 30 40
minutes okay yeah and then I kind of
dropped it so I don't know
yeah
there's there's something on the Wii U
well I appreciate you ever coming
through we had up to like 850 people or
something like that beautiful you know
we had a good hit that like button man
hit tits hit the like button we we love
those likes you know those likes are
amazing we need those likes and I feel
like you guys got liking this podcast is
a crime against against us see the
puppies in Argentina yeah this is why we
can't have adequate new toys
um
you know how it is you know you can find
me going to work and and not playing as
many games as I like to but again uh I I
am I just I'm gonna have to do some a
Mobile upgrade itself
yeah I'm looking at these 40 90 laptops
like I'm gonna need that okay 40 90 some
flow okay yeah yeah so we let's see what
happens but I'm looking towards that so
it's gonna be a fun Year guys like thank
you again for all the support we can't
do it without you guys we're gonna be
doing a lot of stuff running around the
the United States and perhaps Beyond
we'll see
our biggest goal is like you know when
we go to these events we can give you
guys a lot of content at these events
and and we haven't really went to these
events in huge numbers since the
pandemic started yeah you know we might
go to a packs here or there but for the
most part a Pax will be open and E3 will
be closed so this is I think this is the
first year that for the most part all of
the gaming events are going to be open
yeah exactly and we're looking to give
you guys a lot more agency in terms of
what we do and it's gonna be there gonna
be some changes and stuff so uh but
again it's all because again you guys
you guys come in here you engage with us
we want to make sure that you guys are
are watching the show because it's stuff
that you want to see right so uh it's
gonna be gonna be a fun ride this year
yeah no doubt just salute to the realm
no doubt Lloyd chinchilla himself
returns great beard of the watch
smoothest room
this move is nice watching the game
where can I find people find you a
little kid what's going on
first and foremost uh happy birthday to
my brother
you know
um I guess your birthday coming after
the the first I don't know it kind of
really it's always that bro you're
getting one gift yeah like that I always
feel for you on that like especially the
kids who their birthdays is like
Christmas right right next to it yeah
they get the double you mean like you
mean like December 17th yeah yeah maybe
like so since it's Friday we just gave
you my dad's my dad's birthday it is
Christmas Eve it works it works out
though because when your birthday is
close to Christmas you could double
whammy them get one big gift for both if
you want like yeah but
um you know his birthday falls after
everybody's hungover yeah so usually the
second everybody they bringing right
yeah oh man is your birthday my baby so
happy birthday we gotta um sit down and
eat something so we're gonna have a
special dinner uh when we get to uh
packs you know we'll do it baby
um
this is a this is a huge Year yes I know
I mean I came in with uh Keith Murray
since you know Keith Murray's in the
Zeitgeist right now but all stuff that's
going on and when I was listening to the
song I was like yeah man the most
beautiful thing in this world
and we right back at it so it feels good
you know to be on the podcast to have
fun to look at the topics and notice how
a topic will stretch in a way that you
didn't think that it would go to you
know pulse
um shout out to Rand out though for
pulling off you know I like that I like
to play around and joke with them all
the time but you know God bless the dude
uh is on a very uh
um entertaining show and you know he
always looks back and reaches his hand
back to help the homies at all times so
I really respect people like that you
know there's a lot of them we have a lot
of them in this really good Community
whole glow yes if nobody knows uh please
go to hoax page show some support uh say
prayers for Hogue he's not out of the
situation yet as far as where he's at we
won't hold home and we want him home and
all in one piece so you know let's let's
please uh pray
and uh you know just give him some
support so on a gaming this looks like
an incredible year for gaming and we
have conventions like attic was saying
that we're going to be in full force at
we revamping the patreon so we can give
you value there so a lot of this stuff
is going to be behind the paywall guys
as far as getting the stuff early for
those early guys
um there's some stuff that attic and I
is working on so if you like the attack
on Titan stuff that we're talking about
with r r with the Lords we're going to
give you an in-depth look at actually me
watching
some of these shows and you're getting a
chance to see my Royal reactions to
things uh this RNR with the Lords this
Tuesday attic and I is going to be
talking about the new movie Megan and
it's going to be some spoilers there
without going too much into the show
we're also going to talk about a lot of
stuff that's going on in entertainment
so if you guys don't know we talk anime
we talk what's going on in the
entertainment movies uh TV shows
streaming networks and combat talk with
the King it was a great show yesterday
that we had we have over uh two 2 000
people to watch the show already I do
appreciate it thank you so much I love
the support right out the gate that's a
beautiful thing let's make 2023 uh great
again let's make it a great year so I
want everybody to get their Red Hats to
say ILP and you know
I'm gonna come up with those hats you
know it's gonna be IOP hats but it's
gonna be dope as fast
pulling out for a little Cameo Edition
that was cool but it was good to be back
also with just the brothers the hobbies
are just talking again we had a little
high Ace much needed Hiatus and um yeah
we got just a lot of big digs playing a
lot of big things planned and if this
year goes according to playing this
could be one of our hopefully biggest
years yeah looking to hit the shows a
lot of things cooking so please support
again we do we rarely do it but we
really do appreciate the likes it you
know what I'm saying that we really
appreciate you guys sharing the podcast
out all of that stuff helps when we
trying to do bigger things you know
sadly it's not just about the quality of
the content it's also about the metrics
and as much as I hate that stuff you
know and I'm trying to be better about
it so if you can remember you know come
in grab a seat wipe your feet look at
that put that like and then we can do it
click the like button before you wipe
your feet exactly please do and then
also Lords of gaming.net you know so you
see flame in here we've seen uh way hick
in here shout out to Nicholas Downey you
know I'm saying the crew the editorial
the entire team C Unit talk about being
Prince the time everybody doing anything
for the squad you know salute to y'all
that they've been killing it for us
putting in Us in position to do bigger
things and yeah I'm excited so like King
said you know all love and uh we got
some fun things flat I cannot wait but
that's all I got at it oh again hog law
send love to hold the law that is the
homie man please go to that page go to
Mrs at Mrs hoglow on Twitter
go to Whole gloss YouTube channel hit
the community tab you can see updates up
there as well send some love and they
will be doing something to support as
well attic what you got for me before I
roll out
yeah just you know appreciate everyone
for coming through
um
[ __ ]
if everything goes smooth we might have
a nice little guest for you guys next
week
okay we got some again we got things
cooking man this is yeah definitely yeah
so we got four is a legend two dollars
of a chat let's be clear this is an Xbox
podcast
and then we have let me play with you
with uh with let's play with each
other's joists Dave
new year new me
yo he changed his name oh no anyway it
all that I'm gonna be saying that a lot
a lot that's all I got everybody
enjoying your Sunday attic we go for the
checkout we got everything no that
everybody
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]